це тобі
Доброго дня шановні глядачі які
дивляться нас в онлайні з усієї України
і Доброго дня тим хто сьогодні
безпосередньо з нами Ми сьогодні
протягом наступної години до 13
будемо говорити про відновлення та
відбудову ця панель присвячена тому аби
обговорити з тими хто власне відповідає
за політику відновлення
хто безпосередньо за це відповідає і
стикається з питаннями імплементації на
місцях
проговорити те яким буде цей навчальний
рік а головне яка необхідна взаємодія та
допомога регіонам чи постраждали від
війни для того щоб відновити доступ до
освіти для того щоб добре чути цю
розмову будь ласка вмикайте Четвертий
канал у ваших
навушниках там ви маєте чути українську
мову якщо будуть якісь проблеми з зі
звуком кажіть будь ласка технічній
команді
[оплески]
Так вибачте вочевидь тепер це має бути
третя шановна технічна команда вирішить
будь ласка який врешті канал
українська мова
мабуть третя
я в мене також Зараз ми зрозуміємо Яка
третя а в третій Ви чуєте
Це новий новий прекрасний досвід
насправді зараз повернули так Ура Ми є
на третьому каналі так на четвертому
знову
Зараз ми Зачекаємо є
Шановні слухачі учасники Я перепрошую
насправді така в нас вимушена система
тому що це
єдина локація насправді яка має
величезне укриття тому ми мусимо це
враховувати І власне така організація
сьогоднішнього простору Отже ми говоримо
наступну годину про відновлення і з нами
сьогодні на цій панелі є пан Євген
кудрявець перший заступник міністра
освіти і науки а з нами є Анна Юрченко
заступниця міністра розвитку громад
території та інфраструктури
можете припинити це робити будь ласка це
неможливо з тим четвертим каналом все
гаразд добре
з нами є Вікторія тітовас і його bigcity
Lab і головне що з нами є ті хто
безпосередньо на місцях бачать як це
відновлення Який Воно має вигляд це
Віталій ким керівник Миколаївської
обласної військової адміністрації та
Анатолій Федорук е-е голова бучанської
громади яка одна з перших почала власне
відновлення чи чуєте ви мене не чуєте
технічна команда У нас знову немає звуку
і це стає вже трішки складним
Ну а тепер ми чуємо Руслана гурика поки
поки нам повертають наш звук
Євгене
можна можемо продовжити Ура Ми нарешті
не чуємо Руслана гурака і можемо
продовжити говорити власне про
відновлення
пане Віталю Я хотіла би почати з вас
тому що власне Миколаївська область є
однією з тих яка постраждала і продовжує
страждати найбільше в частині доступу до
освіти тому що Кількість шкіл які
понищені в області є просто вражаючою
якою власне є поточна ситуація в
шкільній освіті в області і як
планується навчати новий навчальний рік
якщо ви звісно можете це говорити зараз
публічно а також якщо ми говоримо трішки
трішки довшу перспективу що потрібно аби
відновити цей доступ розуміючи що кожну
з 70+ шкіл в області швидко не відновиш
Доброго дня всім радий вас тут бачити
є презентація яка широко це висвітлює Я
пропоную поїхати в неї а я буду
коментувати Буду намагатися своїми
словами щоб цифри не були нудними
дивіться у нас 33 школи заклади
зруйновані повністю та 246 зазнали
руйнувань і це приблизно 60% - це
капітальні руйнування по області
А дайте мені цей клікер я буду зараз
добре
тому ситуація в області критична щодо
навчання і
історія така що на найближчій навчальний
рік дуже важко відповідати потребам
суспільства бо Всі ходять навчатися
офлайн тому що ми не можемо На жаль
фізично забезпечити безпеку наших дітей
та наших вчителів тому що
окупант посилив обстріли в день зараз є
прольоти по навчальним закладам у Сумах
трагічної у Кривому Розі трагічна і тому
ця ситуація дуже-дуже небезпечно ви
бачите що відбувається не бачити що
відбувається з нашими школами
це вже добре тому ситуація в нас така по
пам'яті 688 у нас школа не відповідають
немає сховищ Ну немає через
специфіку південну бо в нас в дитячих
садочках взагалі не було підвалів навіть
не то що сховищ з 1 000 гаком навчальних
закладів в нас відповідають безпечним
хоча відео принципам це на зараз 75 і ще
110 ми дотягнемо але це все одно 10% від
потреби і це ніяк не вплине на якість
навчального навпаки вплине дуже погано
на якість навчального процесу Тому це
проблема І ми будемо мені далі працювати
ми вже рік працюємо з іноземними
донорами з обласним бюджетом з державним
нам допомагають Дякую вам Анна за те що
ви приділяєте увагу нашим нашій освіті
але це тривалий процес і на жаль через
те що в нас область прифронтова діти
були в онлайн вже більше ніж півтора
року А в деяких областях вони навчалися
і тільки зараз переходять на онлайн ми
будемо щось з цим робити якось
підвищувати рівень але це дуже велика
проблема
що стосується
основних проблем на мою думку ми можемо
разом за програмою президента по
відновленню відбудувати школи стіни
парти але основа на всього навчального
процесу це вчителі наші
викладачі тому що вони все це пережили і
дуже чекають далі щоб відновитися
наприклад в нас там снігурівській школі
дівчинка в окупації здала чотири
предмети на найвищий бал 200 балів цих і
вчителів вона ж працювала в онлайн
вчителів в окупації тобто ці приклади
надихають на те щоб надалі могли ми
працювати і зворотня бік наших вчителів
Наприклад ми В тому році не могли ну
скажемо так відзначати державними
нагородами боялися що потраплять вчителі
в окупацію і там можуть буть
з'явитися проблеми додаткові вчителів
якщо вони будуть відзначені державними
нагородами тому я цього року на 1 жовтня
буду звертатися до міністра щоб більшу
кількість за два роки ми могли подати
вчителів які ну довгий до військових дій
агресивних і під час себе проявили щодо
якості там навчання Ну вони того варті
коментарі а беручи до уваги те що власне
тут є Міністерство освіти Міністерство
відновлення яке на центральному рівні
закладає кошти в державних бюджет е-е
формує субвенції працює в першу чергу з
донорами
якщо ми
з того чи вас я зрозуміла що цей рік -
це онлайн і потрібно працювати над
дистанційкою так над покращенням якості
І звісно надо облаштуванням укриттів
проте якщо ми будемо сподіватися що
ситуація покращиться Якими можуть бути
якісь швидші гнучкі рішення про по
відновленню доступу до освіти я просто
ну кілька тижнів в тому проїхала
половину Миколаївської області до
окуповані громади абсолютно в кожному
селищі зруйновані якщо не всі то 90%
шкіл і Ну я не уявляю коли їх там всі
відбудують тобто чи є у вас от ну
видово-бі креативне управління це
можливо це якісь модульні рішення
можливо це якісь тимчасові школи бо якщо
Головне що там є - це діти і їх там стає
більше
ви знаєте
тут треба ділити на те що я хочу знаю що
можна розказати Ну тут Звичайно є Ну
давайте так є міні-клас і міні-школи
мені садочки які зараз ми відкриваємо в
тому числі в лікарнях таке щоби ну
справдити дітей для того щоб це
працювало це програма нагадайте є
фоскілс і
так і ми відкриваємо маленькі школи для
того щоб завантажити їх потрохи щоб
розрядити не в школах де є укриття Тобто
ми не в школах зосереджемо а викриттях
там де укриття ми туди там організовуємо
школу щоб можливо навчатися і питання в
чому якось ну іде реформа освіти так і
там де слабка освіта бали так воно ще
слабкіше тому що інститути вчителі
Як то кажуть Престиж і в нас ситуація -
це ще погіршується через те що в нас
війна ну бойові дії активні і зруйнована
і Саме через це ми не можемо надати
якісні
наздогнати як би Ми не працювали швидко
в нас по укриттям для дитя для закладів
освіти потреби в 6,7 млрд грн якщо вони
будуть завтра Я це буду робити фізично
дуже довго тому що не всі готові
працювати під обстрілами скажемо є в нас
там дві громади вщент зруйнований і там
немає донорів а там снігурівки вже є
донори там більш спокійно і це
стосується дітей тобто і батьків бо вони
хотять безпеки своїх дітям звісно ми
будемо приймати Давайте так
відповідні рішення щодо безпечної
частини яка там 150 км від лінії фронту
але ті що рядом - це дуже велика
проблема І ми будемо просити системної
допомоги в тому числі на підтримку
вчителів для відновлення рівня освіти на
тих територіях які постраждали найбільше
Дякую вам пане Анатолію ви були
тією тим населеним пунктом цієї громадою
яка розпочала відновлення однією з
перших після деокупації
завдяки збройним силам України Скажіть
будь ласка як відрізняється ситуація з
доступом до освіти в Бучі в громаді на
початку минулого навчального року і
поточного І от на вашу думку чи стала
освіта чинником повернення до громади
Доброго дня шановні учасники заходу перш
за все організаторам хочу подякувати за
запрошення і відразу відповідно
запитання те яке сьогодні є актуальним
всі освітні загальноосвітні заклади
дошкільні бучанської міської
територіальної громади які звісно
вціліли їх можна було відновити до
навчального року на 1 вересня є готовими
і в тому числі з безпекових питань з
укриттями але рік тому назад і ви
абсолютно праві як певний такий
лакмусовий папірець був у нас як певний
іспит здавала місцева Влада разом з
регіональною і державною на 1 вересня
Минулого року тому що із 17-ти
загальноосвітніх шкіл і 15-ти дошкільних
навчальних закладів практично жоден не
вцілів і всі знали різного ступеня
руйнації і нам надзвичайно важливо було
аби на 1 вересня як такий Рубікон
фактично в організації життя в кожному
із населених пунктів зробити все можливе
і продемонструвати
нашими громадянами педагогам батькам
учням щоб повертатися на окуповану
територію місто Буча уже безпечно мало
того і необхідно тому що місто без
жителів ви Самі розумієте немає ніякої
перспективи і дійсно 1 вересня Минулого
року виходячи навіть з тих
процесів по відновленню які ми проводили
було таким знаковим для нас моментом а
поточний рік фактично Уже ми в кожному
дошкільному кожній загальноосвітній
школі обладнали відповідні укриття як за
рахунок коштів місцевого бюджету
державні програми там
так по чуть-чуть участвовали в цьому А в
основному це донорські кошти в силу
певної специфіки багато хто із
донорських організацій прагнув аби в
їхньому портфоліо бедраменті була Буча
звучала і якісь дошкільний чи
загальноосвітні навчальний заклад
сумарно на відновлення тих закладів які
можна було відновити
використали фінансову ресурсу 86
мільйонів гривень
донорська якраз допомога фінансування
різних місій
освітньою галузі майже 50 мільйонів
склали Тобто ми констатуємо що станом на
1 вересня навіть збільшилась кількість
учнів першокласників і мені тут відділу
освіти підготував цифри якщо в минулому
році на 1 вересня у нас
першокласники було 890 То нині в
поточному році ситуація 924 практично
майже всі діти які були на обліку
реєструвалися в школах садочках в силу
безпекових питань завдяки збройним силам
України повернулися і це нас тішить
вселяє впевненість в тому що
ми неправильному шляху Дякую пане
Анатолій Я навіть не знаю В цих умовах
чи доречно питати Як ви розпочнете цей
навчальний рік та тому що є безпекові
моменти які можна або не можна
оголошувати проте
Чи буде у вас загалом можливість вийти
принаймні в змішаний формат Які у вас
плани
з вересня з того переліку ми проводили
опитування безпеки питання є понад усе в
організації навчального процесу як то
дошкільному так і загальноосвітніх
школах лише три навчальні заклади будуть
мати змішану форму навчання це по
рішенню батьків і в певній мірі навіть
педагогічну колективу всі решта очна
форма навчання Ми віримо ЗСУ безпеку
питання забезпечені забезпечені потребою
скільки навчається в загальноосвітній
школі стільки і передбачено укриттю в
цих приміщеннях
Дякую дуже насправді це такий хороший
приклад того що
за рік фактично трішечки більше можна
відновити в невеликому населеному пункті
так повноцінно-освітньої інфраструктуру
але все залежить врешті від якщо
вони стріляють то можна відновлювати І
дійсно за рік це можна зробити Дякую
Євгене ми бачимо абсолютно різну
ситуацію так Київщина яка захищена яка
не обстрілюється з
кордону з півночі
і миколаївщини Та це два різні регіони і
На жаль ми живемо в той час коли
більшість наших областей потребують дуже
різних підходів Чи можете ви коротко
окреслити яка загалом ситуація по
Україні тому що Міністерство освіти
збирало дані по доступу перед початком
навчального року а друге власне питання
А що таке для Міністерства освіти
відновлення доступу до освіти який у вас
план в умовах коли різні регіони Мають
дуже різні ситуації але що вони мають
спільного це діти діти які повертаються
в тому числі на деокуповані території в
тій же Миколаївській області дякую дякую
для нас дійсно дуже важливе сьогодні
питання відновлення доступу до освіти і
взагалі відновлення доступу до освіти
воно Дуже схоже з тим форматом який у
нас сьогодні з вами ми з вами вживу
вперше за багато років проводимо
конференцію де освітяни з усієї України
можуть поділитися досвідом почути думки
один одного і це зовсім інший досвід це
не те що ми там тільки в онлайні
говоримо про проблеми їх звісно
розуміємо ми чітко розуміємо що
відновлення доступу це в першу чергу
якість і
по статистиці яку ми зараз забираємо з
тим що ми працюємо ми будемо знати точні
цифри фінальні вже 5 вересня коли буде
оновлена мережа буде оновлений мережевий
Комі але зараз на екрані Ви можете
бачити ситуацію по
поточну ситуацію по різним регіонам
перше дуже світле це голубеньке таке це
живе навчання очне синє це змішане
навчання і помаранчеве - це повністю
навчання в режимі
дистанційному в режимі онлайн звісно ми
бачимо на найменші показники у
запорізької Харківської Луганської
Донецької Херсонської області там де
найбільш небезпеки і йдуть постійні
обстріли Миколаївська область
яка нічим не далі ніж Миколаївська від
фронту який просто зараз менш взагалі
аналіз цієї таблиці цього графу Він дуже
дуже цікавий з точки зору того ми бачимо
допустимо Волинської області яка також
має достатньо великий відсоток
змішаного навчання і онлайн навчання так
як вони теж попадають під 50-кілометрову
зону і по правилах теж не можуть
виводити там дітей але є позитив
однозначно в порівнянні з
вересня 2022 року
дистанційно вийде на 450 тисяч дітей
менше Майже всі вони додадуться в
кількість дітей які будуть мати очне
навчання за розподілом приблизно ми
маємо
очне навчання близько 50% випадків дітей
Вони будуть навчатися
фізично в школах
дистанційно цього року ідуть вперше в
клас
880 тисяч дітей з них приблизно 400
тисяч перебувають за кордоном ті які
залишаються в українській системі освіти
і 880 тисяч з них
400 будуть перебувати за кордоном в
цілому ми бачимо ситуацію що на 1800
шкіл більше вийде бочне навчання цього
року ніж 1 вересня Минулого року маємо
на 500 шкіл менше які будуть працювати в
дистанційному форматі тобто фактично ми
йдемо до того що дистанційно но цього
року буде навчатися лише
2400 шкіл інші школи будуть Навчатися
або очно або в змішаному форматі в
порівнянні з минулим роком ми бачимо
суттєве зростання кількості дітей які
будуть навчатися очно і фінальну
кількість дітей які будуть в системі
освіти Ми зможемо розуміти Буквально за
тиждень але з попередніх оцінок Сьогодні
ми бачимо суттєве зростання кількості
дітей які будуть навчатися очно
можна наступний сайт будь ласка така в
нас певна несправедливість лише в
Міністерство освіти працює презентація
Перепрошую решту спікерів
Я кажу Євгене ще така несправедливість у
нас ще лише Міністерство освіти працює
презентація щось мабуть ви зробили
інакше Ну мабуть півпанелі вже було щоб
налагодити просто це явно
для нас питання А на правильно дуже
питання щодо того що таке доступ
відновлення доступу до освіти Ми
говоримо про 4 ключових принципи по
відновленню доступу в першу чергу це
безпека це якість укриттів не відкривати
школи де може бути
суттєва небезпека відповідно безпека -
це номер один якщо ви бачите зараз на
екрані Ми
хочемо сказати що дуже велику роль
відіграли органи місцевого
самоврядування цього року ми маємо
підтвердження що силами органів
місцевого самоврядування було відкрито
додаткових тисячу сховищ за один рік
плюс ще 280 буде побудовано за рахунок
державної субвенції до кінця року будуть
ці об'єкти введення в експлуатацію ми
маємо розуміти що маємо забезпечувати
при відновленні доступу думати не тільки
про тих хто повертається безпосередньо
до школи Ми в тому числі говоримо про те
якою має бути якість онлайн освіти і
створення доступу до онлайн-освіти якщо
немає на сьогоднішній день можливості
відкрити школу це в першу чергу
забезпечення девайсами там де у дітей
немає можливості багато юнісеф і фон та
Олени зеленської працює над тим щоб
забезпечувати
девайсами дітей по всіх регіонах і це
дозволяє забезпечити рівність доступу до
освіти Також ми працюємо над пошуком
рішенням що прискорюють відбудову
спільними зусиллями з міністерством
інфраструктури з донорами для того щоб
там до школи повністю зруйновані або
пошкоджені є Навіть якщо при наявності
укриттів треба відновити відновити школу
в першу чергу ми бачимо на сьогоднішній
день Що є дефіцит всім з половиною тисяч
сховищ по країні з них 2 300 не можемо
зараз навіть будувати тому вони є в зоні
бойових дій і дуже близько до кордону з
фронтом це 2300 укриттів не можуть бути
побудовані і наша ціль - це зараз
5200 укриттів які мають бути облаштовані
або побудовані з нуля в 2,500 може бути
побудовані з нуля зараз працюємо по
дорученню президента спільно з
прем'єр-міністром над тим щоб
пріоритеті стоїть питання укритів І ми
хочемо зараз працювати активно з
донорами для того щоб з великими
країнами для того щоб укриття наступного
року можна було будувати тому в першу
чергу Немає безпекових умов відповідно
треба забезпечувати якісний онлайн
офлайн онлайн і для нас відновлення
доступу те це в тому числі надолуження
освітніх втрат Це в тому числі допомога
дітям і вчителям якщо вони повертаються
до навчання навіть за безпекових умов у
них багато викликів А що мені робити з
дітьми які там не до кінця освоїли
програму А що робити з тими хто має
бути забезпечений ментальною підтримкою
і так далі тому дуже багато безпекових
питань також м'яких це теж пріоритеті
сьогодні у нашої команди Євгена Дуже
дякую Я насправді так допитуюся про це
що таке відновлення доступу тому що я
дуже багато чую принаймні читаю в
новинах так давайте так що там уряд веде
перемовини з певними країнами чи з
міжнародними організаціями про відбудову
шкіл і коли приїздиш Ну знову ж таки в
миколаївську область то тобі очевидно що
там кожну школу Просто я не знаю коли
відбудують тому що це мільярди доларів і
мають бути інші рішення я там наприклад
не буду називати населені пункти але
десь ми У фонді робимо крило амбулаторія
переобладнаємо в
невеличку школу десь це школа під землею
тому що там круте 2000 квадратів Перу
Яке Просто треба відремонтувати та і це
будуть ну фактично тимчасові школи
або наприклад на Київщині приклад який
можна назвати в Богданівці це під
броварами знищили абсолютно все спалено
підірвано вся інфраструктура там
переробили будинок культури в невелику
школу і це зараз єдине приміщення Коли
куди ходять діти і власне пані Анна У
мене до вас питання
яке місце освіти у плані відновлення і
які пріоритети з точки зору того Якими
мають бути формати цього відновлення ви
закладаєте у перемовини з міжнародними
партнерами тому що власне він
відновлення і віце-прем'єр кубриков з
того що я бачу є ключовими
переговорниками так у
з нашими партнерами дякую дякую
навчання онлайн в нас вже йде
рік і не два це вже велика це вже
напевно фактично 4 роки коли наші діти
навчаються онлайн і да і є вже учні які
будуть 1 вересня підуть в 5 клас і
потенційно вони п'ятий рік будуть
навчатися онлайн це учні які не бачили
школи офлайн тому коли ми говоримо з
міністерством освіти вони нас просять
давайте сфокусуємося на те яким чином
максимально вивести наших учнів офлайн
для того щоб Вони відвідували школу і
тут ми говоримо не тільки про ці регіони
де фактично школи були пошкоджені
збройною агресією чи фактично зруйновані
але також ми говоримо про ці регіони де
в нас є величезна кількість внутрішньо
переміщених осіб
чому чому школа для нас важливі чому
заклади освіти для нас важливі це не
тільки відновлення і якість надання
освітніх послуг Це в тому числі
економічна діяльність регіону це
економічна діяльність громади
жодна матір напевно не повернеться в
свою громаду якщо вона не буде розуміти
що їй дитина може відвідувати школу
офлайн що вона знаходиться в безпечній
безпечному середовищі що ця школа має
укриття що це укриття має якісь певні
якісні характеристики і це
більш-менш комфортне середовище де
дитина може перебувати якщо матір не
повернеться в цю громаду
про відновлення економічної діяльності
громади буде складно говорити тому що
наші чоловіки Вони захищають державу
жінки в свою чергу вони в певних
локаціях вже становляться такими
драйверами скажемо так хоч якоїсь
економічної діяльності там малого
бізнесу і так далі тому відновлення
закладів освіти це вся територія України
Це абсолютно всі регіони і в цьому році
ми зосереджені разом з міносвіти на
відбудові і покращення умов цих закладах
і також ми зосереджені на тому щоб
відбудувати або в деяких локаціях з нуля
збудувати укриття
ресурс який ми використовуємо в цьому
році це абсолютно все що можна знайти і
все що можливо доступним бути в Україні
це і кошти державного бюджету
окрім тих коштів які виділяються самі
Власне кажучи місцеві органи влади за
своїх місцевих бюджетів
це фонд ліквідації наслідків це
спеціальний фонд спеціальний Фонд
державного бюджету з якого вже
виділено ресурс
більше ніж на 100 шкіл для того щоб їх
відновити це живі гроші які шляхом
субвенції спускаються на місця для того
щоб відбудовувати школи будувати
укриттям це і донорські програми це
кредитні програми з Європейським
інвестиційним банком і більше ніж 100
об'єктів також відібрано вже в рамках
цих програм і фактично почалось
фінансування багатьох з шкіл по всій
території України не треба також
забувати про
донорські програми які реалізують це
через
через організацію ООН це проекти які
фінансуються через UNDP через юнобс Де
йде мова про те щоб забезпечити
комфортне
перебування або наприклад десь
укрупнення якихось закладів освіти і
десь переорієнтувати
перемістити учнів з однієї школи в іншу
школу і так далі ці проекти Ми
продовжуємо фактично реалізувати окрім
того ми почали перемовини також з рядом
інших
банків-реконструкції які будуть
допомагати В цьому це і фонди грантів
грантові фонди і це також кредитні
ресурси які буде залучати безпосередньо
держава для того щоб відбудувати тому що
це один з найбільших пріоритетів
Дякую щиро за відповідь таке уточнення
ви сказали про близько 100 шкіл які
будуть відбудовуватися за кошти
наших партнерів і зокрема Богданівка яку
я згадувала тобто те село в якому почали
працювати в одному з перших і там власне
школа буде відбудовуватися за кошти
європейського інвестиційного банку і
коли ми туди приїхали з європейськими
колегами вони кажуть Та це класно Ну це
школа тут буде років через 5-6 І що
робити при цьому ця школа ну яка де-юра
збереглася вона каже ну ми дітей
втрачаємо тому що вони тепер їздить в
іншу школу і фактично
населений пункт втрачає дітей і кошти і
таке інше відповідно моє питання Як ви
перший період і громади яким Ви
допомагаєте а друге чи можна все ж
закладати Ось такі гнучкі рішення не
просто повні повноцінне відбудова школи
це ідеальний варіант проте він поки що
мабуть неможливий в снігурівці в яку
може знову прилетіти але ось пам'яталі
згадував про інші варіанти відновлення
доступу та якісь якби шкільні осередки
не в школах чи можна це закладати
так
це таке питання цікаве і ми його
Стараємося як Міністерство комунікувати
Тому що
інколи коли ми отримаємо пропозиції від
місцевих органів влади в нас об'єкти
можуть звучати на перший погляд Досить
дивно наприклад відбудова
не знаю сільського клубу відбудова
якогось театру і ти перший раз коли
дивишся ці об'єкти ти не розумієш ну які
театр якщо тут поряд тебе ніхто не йде в
школу і в нас об'єкти ці
культурні Вони стають такими
мультифункціональними да об'єктами де в
нас і переміщені якісь певні класи і ми
розуміємо що йде певне перепрофалювання
цих об'єктів і так далі тому да Інколи
ми підтримуємо ці об'єкти вони те що я
говорю вони звучать Досить дивно
здається на перший погляд що це
абсолютно навіть не десятий пріоритет
але ми розуміємо що це об'єкти там
двійного треного призначення тому що
наприклад цей об'єкт має хоч якесь
приміщення яке може бути
перепрофільоване під укриття тоді можна
хоч якось продовжити навчання тому такі
рішення є Я бачила питання в Італії і
але в мене ще була коротке питання про
пріоритезацію регіонів і громад Як ви
обираєте пріоритети
в нас по пріоритезації в нас є методика
пріоритетизації в цілому відбудови які
сектори є першим пріоритетом це там
критична інфраструктура наприклад сфера
житлово-комунального господарства і так
далі соціальна інфраструктура потім ми
починаємо говорити про пріоритезацію
регіонів і тут не можна сказати що один
регіон буде більш пріоритетним ніж іншою
тому що десь школа зруйнована але
наприклад безпекова ситуація не дозволяє
і жоден донор не дозволить прийти туди і
відбудовувати там десь безпекова
ситуація краща але там величезна
кількість внутрішньо переміщених осіб
тому ми говоримо про те що фактично в
нас відбудова закладів освіти
відбуваються абсолютно в кожній області
немає жодної області яка не покрита Да
ми розуміємо що це абсолютно не той
ресурс фінансовий який нам би всім
хотілось мати на відбудову але але певно
це той максимум який ми на сьогоднішній
день Як держава можемо дозволити собі
дякую Віталій у вас було питання чи
Дякую Ну насправді це не питання
Насправді Я хочу з власного досвіду
внести трохи реальності
дивіться є регіони чи області чи села де
люди виживають і вони можуть там
попасти під обстріл коли йдуть до школи
за хлібом і таке інше там не йде мова
про якісне освіту це неможливо є регіон
якийсь десь посередині де і можна але
дуже зруйновані і важко і ніхто не хоче
туди їхати бо що воно буде є регіони де
один раз за півтора роки був прильот на
всю область наприклад це зовсім різні
речі друга ситуація ми ж ділимо так
найпростіше укриття на
протирадіаційне і на бомбосховище я бачу
статистику ну Вибачте але реальних
бомбосховищ ну в 10 разів менше ті хто
хоче відкриватися і там ну досить
безпечно Та будь ласка від там уламків
що збили там якийсь мопед чи щось трохи
там скло вибить це забезпечить безпеку
дітей але це треба на законодавчому
рівні закріпи- закріпити і ніяке
найпростіше укриття на лінії запорі
Херсонської там овчарки Миколаївської
області чи там Донецька Луганський чи
Харкова не витримає попадання снаряд і
не можна навіть якщо там є покриття
відправляти туди дітей це другий
важливий пункт який треба урегулювати да
прийняти всі зараз ДБН і це приводиться
до тями але це все час і третя треба
ділити на е-е якість будівництва якщо це
село і там з цегли з глини побудовано
школа Вона вся засипеться якщо поруч
прилетить я що це нова школа в Києві Ну
я Для прикладу яка зароблена залізо та
бетона її нічого не буде якщо там щось
прилетить це треба все диференціювати не
можна взяти один принцип розтягнути на
всю країну Це я дуже прошу враховувати
дуже Дякую це дуже слушно Шкода що немає
Мустафи або його колег з відповідною
агенції але я дуже погоджуюся тому що в
різних регіонах в яких Там ми працюємо
як фонд скрізь своя чомусь поведінка у
ДСНС у всіх якісь свої креативні правила
і це насправді вже дуже
набридло да тому що кожного разу
вигадують щось нове а потім
правоохоронні органи долучаються до
цього до цієї творчості тому тут
Міністерство відновлення Міністерства
освіти та Італії я просто знаю що в
місті Миколаєві там зараз цікаві Вибачте
І я б хотів би сказати про те що можливо
для того щоб забезпечити рівень освіти
треба як якихось переходні моделі
наприклад як цифрові освітні центри які
помаленьку які там робляться за приватні
гроші маленькі але це треба утримувати і
наша моя чергова ну в області задача
утримати наших фахівців вчителів щоб
вони не поїхали кудись і інше нам зараз
є профте освіта яка потребує професій на
відновлення нашої країни і це ми зараз
навіть не обговорюємо але ці програми є
і теж міжнародні які повинні бути для
того щоб в нас були кадри бізнес не
повернеться коли в нас не буде
кваліфікований кадрів бо вони хлопці і
дівчата ці на війні і нам потрібні кадри
для відновлення для відновлення шкіл Нам
потрібні кадри які ми маємо навчити той
теж Тобто це така циклічність і в
регіонах які кризові на зараз треба
уділяти саме людям увагу і компенсувати
субвенції програми для
стимулювання будь-що бо якщо б я був
вчителем я би вставив з Херсону і поїхав
до Львова навчатись ну вибачте
Дякую ми насправді про повноваження і
взаємодію Поговоримо в другому раунді в
останніх 13-ти хвилинах нашої розмови
тому що Ну в мене є таке відчуття що
бракує Ось цього діалогу між різними
регіонами які дуже в різні ситуації і
центральним рівнем я розумію чому Тому
що Ну коли працюєш в Києві ти складно
розуміти як дійсно реально виглядає
ситуація в Миколаєві в Херсоні і і в
Харкові це це різні різні
контексти дуже часто а-а проте перед цим
раунтом другим Я хотіла би запросити до
слова Вікторію тітову Вікторія є всі
його Big City Lab коротко розповім Big
City Lab - це е-е власне проєкт
організація які нещодавно уклали
партнерство з урядом з міністерствами
цифрової трансформації міністерством
освіти щодо трансформації освітніх
просторів України і це такий один з
підходів того як ми можемо
відновлювати на трішки інших принципах
знову ж таки можливо це зараз не рішення
для тих
регіонів які під великим ризиком проте
для таких
областей як Київщина наприклад Та це
може бути дійсно дуже хороша ідея вікон
тобі слово дякую доброго дня На що ми на
що ми спробували подивитися ми
спробували подивитися яким чином можна
робити відбудову і швидко і при цьому
зберігати якість і підходити до неї
систем листочки зору архітектури якщо
можна наступний слайд будь ласка
чому потрібно переосмислювати Я думаю не
потрібно нікому зараз пояснювати в нас
тут сьогодні всі освітяни на фотографіях
це
фотографія верхня це школа посередині це
лікарня і знизу це тюрма ну якби це
принцип радянської архітектури ось так
будувалися в принципі все і не було
місця для особистості відповідно якщо ми
говоримо про відбудову шкіл нам
недостатньо просто вставити назад вікна
утеплити пофарбувати зробити укриття і
поставити нові меблі нам важливо зробити
так щоб нові школи після відбудови тобто
що таке build Bad Butter да всі про це
говорять що таке Better Поки що немає
розуміння і це те що наша команда
намагається зараз привнести тобто яким
чином ми привідбудові трансформуємо
освітній простір так щоб після
реконструкції школа стара звичайна
Радянська Школа була відповідала
потребам дітей і вчителів
в освітньому процесі наступний слайд
будь ласка
ця ідея нашої команди народилася коли ми
працювали з Маріуполь Реборн над візою
візією відбудови Маріуполя після
декупації Це взагалі такий перший підхід
подивитися на те як можна працювати з
містом коли його звільнять ми в цьому
плані дуже великі оптимісти і коли вони
несли ну якби все місто аналізували але
коли ми дійшли до питання освіти і
нанесли на карту всі школи дитсадочки ми
побачили що тут статистика по школах але
з дитсадочками та сама історія що
повторюється одні й ті самі форми на
карті 72% всіх шкіл Маріуполя це 5
типових будівель відповідно
логічно зробити 5 проектів дуже крутих
дуже класних запросити людей які в цьому
дуже гарно розуміються зробити
колаборації між українськими
європейськими архітекторами для того щоб
потім ці проекти десятки разів
маштабувати по маріуполю наступна наша
думка була далі будь ласка
що Маріуполь вже не унікальний це місто
яке було дуже активно забудоване в
50-60-ті роки радянським союзом
відповідно такі райони вони є у всіх
містах України
на східній на сході їх більше на заході
трошки менше Але тим не менш ми
подивилися на деокуповані області і це
статистика певних областях тобто в нас є
300 000 шкіл всеми областях з них
пошкоджені 835 але при цьому відновленню
з них підлягають 745 тобто нас немає
такої супер великої потреби будувати
тисячі нових шкіл в нас є дуже багато
шкіл які можна відновити просто питання
в тому щоб робити це розумно далі ми
поговорили там з міністерством освіти з
місцевою владою і вони від себе назвали
пріоритетні до відбудови 403 це і в те
що включає мережу і питання того де є
діти де немає дітей де безпечно
відбудовувати до небезпечно і так далі І
з цих чотирьох та трьох шкіл 134 є п'ять
типів
тобто третини зводиться до 5
архітектурних проектів при цьому в цих в
цій третині навчається майже половина
дітей тому що радянські школи це
зазвичай досить великі школи а школи які
не є типовими в Україні вони не всі Але
часто це маленькі сільські школи які в
рамках мережі
можуть наприклад бути об'єднані бо ну
всі ж розуміють що в нас 15 тисяч шкіл
всього в країні і далеко не кожна з них
залишиться після
осмислення мережі і Відповідно ми
подивилися що є ось ці п'ять типів
будівель і ми запропонували разом з
Маріуполь Реборн ми запропонували
Міністерство освіти таку програму
Давайте ми зробимо 5 пілотів подивимось
на кожен з цих типів і спробуємо їх
переосмислити наступний слайд будь ласка
Що Ми включаємо в переосмислення наші
всім принципи трансформації це якби
безумовно укриття
беззаперечно зрозуміло Чому другий
принцип - це мультифункціональність
тобто якщо ми робимо наприклад актову
залу То в неї має бути багато функцій це
є клас для балету це і класна для
концерту це і місце для дітей які
відпочивають там кожен день коли немає
ніяких заходів це і місце збору громади
і так далі Тобто всі простори які можна
зробити мультифункціональними мають
такими бути другу - це школа як місце
для громади я думаю там більшість
директорів які сьогодні і там
представників відділів освіти місцевих
Влад які сьогодні тут є у всіх був
досвід в облаштування укриття для всієї
громади їдальні готували всіх місцевих і
всіх військових і так далі тобто школа -
це таке місце безпеки в яке всі прийшли
на початку війни і вона і має таким
залишатися Тобто привіт будові там
наприклад в містах яких дуже багато
руйнувань або в селах яких в принципі
ніколи не було
інфраструктури спортивні майданчики чи
кінотеатри чи кафе чи громадській
бібліотеки і так далі з'являться не
швидко а школа - це величезна
інфраструктура яка вміщує в собі всі ці
функції які можуть бути відкритими для
громади тоді коли не відбувається
освітній процесі нам для цього потрібно
бути готовими Я знаю всі ці питання і
про санстанцію що можна ще не можна але
давайте розглянемо цю ідею
відповідно те мабуть є ще щось знизу але
чомусь в мене обрізається слайд тому я
не бачу що там е-е стали підхід
зрозуміло ми ми підходимо до того щоб
якщо це можна відновити це вже і дешевше
і екологічніше і краще для нас ніж
зносити і будувати з нуля спільні
простори це проти О дякую
спільні простори це про те що ми
поговорили е-е з вчителями і директорами
провели дослідження і виявили що Окей
діти знаходяться в школі по 7-8 годин
але з них вони там шість з половиною
знаходяться в класі
навіть коли вони з нього виходять їм
немає куди піти бо ти по Верденська
Школа це клас коридор Клас коридор і є
звичайно Там деякі школи які намагаються
облаштувати цей простір самостійно але
як такого рішення немає тому ми дивимось
на те як створити максимум спільних
просторів діти могли проводити час поза
межами класу і те саме стосується
шкільного подвір'я тому що подвір'я це
взагалі мабуть найцікавіший простір в
школі мати можливість вийти на подвір'я
займатися там і іграми і спілкуватися і
при цьому знайти куточок для усумітнення
це якби дуже важлива для дітей і
Дякую що прилистали вниз тому що мабуть
головний принцип з яким Наша команда
багато працюють це безбар'єрність ми
розробляли альбом безбар'єрних рішень в
рамках ініціативи першої Леді і
безумовно всіх школах з якими ми будемо
працювати ми будемо дивитися щоб вся
інфраструктура була максимально
доступною
і остання але теж не менш важливе це
сучасний дизайн для мене як для людини
яка працює з архітектурою в публічному
секторі найгірше це коли витрачається
державні кошти донорські кошти на щось
на якусь відбудову реконструкцію
будівництву нового і воно зроблено
негарно неякісно застаріло тобто Вона
виходить з експертизи або або здається
акт прийому передачі і воно вже
застаріло на 30 років морально і
відповідно якщо ми вже відбудовуємо то
важливо робити це сучасне питання до вас
це все-таки такий перш за все давай
поговоримо трішки як ви це плануєте
реалізовувати тому що у вас є рішення
архітектурне і тепер ви будете шукати
власне пілотні школи знайшли які це
області якщо не секрет це Київська
Харківська Запорізька і Дніпропетровськ
тобто у вас уже будуть пілоти де ви
будете це реалізовувати чи можеш сказати
Ну бо нас слухає багато громад в онлайні
дивіться чи можуть словами вони
контактувати з приводу того щоб власне
ставати вашому партнерами в майбутньому
котику Ми відновили звичайно дивіться
Пілот він вже Чому він Пілот тому що ми
перевіряємо ми тестуємо всі наші
гіпотези напрацьовуємо їх ми цього року
проектуємо наступного будуємо відповідно
вже з наступного року ми можемо заходити
в проектування нових шкіл відповідно
безумовно контактуйте більше того в нас
на сайті є відкритий опитувальник для
директорів для вчителів на який ми
збираємо відповіді з приводу того який у
вас запит на освітній простір там уже
там декілька сотень відповідей і ми це
все проаналізуємо і це лягає в основу
для
технічного завдання для архітекторів
Дуже дякую у нас залишилося буквально 10
хвилин і нас тут слухають переважно
управлінці або керівники громад або
представники громад або директори шкіл і
головне в нас є два ключових
Міністерства і представники громад та в
панелі і мене насправді дуже турбує
питання
зауважень у відновленні і координації
цього процесу І власне в попередньому
раунді питання це стало також трішки
трішки помітно пан Віталій У мене до вас
перше питання якою є роль області у
відновленні зараз та тому що ну є гроші
Він відновлення є якісь мільярди є
субвенції
але є ваші пріоритети і ваша реальність
в області і ваші варіанти рішень як це
зараз влаштовано і як на вашу думку це
мало би бути найефективніше Дякую за
запитання я буду відвертий ми від вас
нічого і не вчимо Справа в тому коли
йдеться мова про будівництво в регіонах
де є в кожному регіоні специфіка є
терміни є завдання які потрібно
вирішувати не тільки як відправити листа
то і це щоденна робота з людьми фейс у
фейс то це завдання яке може виконати
лише на місцях місцева Влада чи його
військова адміністрація що стосується
міністерств і так це на зараз складні
питання повертаються назад до
Департаменту регіонального розвитку
офісу президента і офіс президента
головам увага ставить задача для того
щоб пришвидшувати це питання так чи
інакше відповідальність буде лежати на
місцевому самоврядуванні та органах
державної влади на місцях Це моя
особиста думка по-іншому не буде можна
будувати на
державному рівні уніфіковані речі такі
як дороги там заводи мости це
уніфіковані речі Вони будуються швидко
що стосуються
прив'язки до місцевості та особливості
це все проблематика з яким має працювати
місцева Влада Тим паче що гроші
проектування на прив'язку до місцевості
на мережі все одно лягає на місцеву
владу тому моя особиста думка що воно
має йти через
місцеві органи самоврядування та
обласні адміністрації
А можна тоді практичніше ось зараз
посили Наскільки я знаю будуть уряд буде
працювати дуже предметно з ЄС по цим 55
млрд євро які мають один відновлення
зокрема і сподіваюсь Там будуть гроші на
освіту будуть плануватися нові субвенції
в новий державний бюджет як би мало бути
влаштовано ось ця координація власне з
області так от як часто технічно я я це
допитувався сидять ці двоє представників
власне ключових міністерств Я хочу щоб
всі пішли з якимось ТЗ для себе дайте
мікрофон Віталій будь ласка дякую тут
ларчик просто открывался Ну насправді
треба брати по питомній вазі знищеного
чи проблематики кожен регіон і гроші які
ми маємо Згідно цього відсотку
розподіляти між найбільш областями які
більш цього потребують чи якщо є
стратегічна програма в Міністерство
одного чи іншого вони цю програму
виписують і кажуть хлопці Почекайте оця
стратегічна програма важлива ми
концентру ємо гроші туди але це має бути
прозоро прозоро і зрозуміло бо зараз
відбувається Так У кого є проект хто
швидше біжить то й отримує гроші а це не
як не вирішує глобальну задачу чи не
вирішує стратегію державну по
відновленню наприклад освіти тому якщо
міністр надання Міністерство якраз і є
створити стратегію ефективну діючу і
потім його спустити на виконання
виконавців А в нас зараз трохи
тут є гроші тут є така програма тут таке
і ми все намагаємося швидко зробити це
потребує Люди зараз бо в нас руйнуються
щодня але я вважаю що потрібно
стратегічно зрозуміти де ми в якому
регіоні Що ми робимо може бути
профспіналізацію важливих геох я не знаю
я не фахівець в цьому питанні але точно
ми маємо розуміти план найближчі 10
років щоб ми працювали згідно плану і
тоді воно буде якимось результатом Так
ми затикаємо дірки Дякую власне Так на
жаль трапилося субвенцію наприклад на
укриття Женю не сприйму це Особисто я
знаю це не твоє питання але наприклад
коли ми кажемо що в нас є 10 днів
отримати
пропозиції на укриття тільки ти тільки
ті які є пру То це означає що всі решта
у нас просто відрізаються байдифолт А я
зараз перейдем до центрального рівня в
мене підхід спочатку громади області а
потім потім Київ П Анатолій Яка ваша
думка Я розумію що у вас геть інша
ситуація раніше на миколаївщині проте як
має бути влаштована ця взаємодія з
центральним рівнем щодо відновлення
тут абсолютно
дав відповідь а я про розпорядження
коштами хто буде розпорядником їх і
позиція донорів міжнародних донорів в
тому числі і місцевого самоврядування
співпадає єдине що 50 на 50 центральний
рівень агенція з відновлення
Міністерства Це дійсно великий
інфраструктурні проекти які стосуються
великого кола громад людей а якщо мова
йде про укриття в громаді або
відновлення школи то відповідно цим
розпорядником має бути територіальна
громада навіть не обласна військова
адміністрація але з вашого дозволу Я
трішечки бо ми навчання безпеки питання
не зовсім про харчування не говорили в
школах який ризик існує сьогодні
виходячи із тих інвеститів які ми бачимо
а це невід'ємна частина навчального
процесу
громади які зазнали окупації або на
лінії зіткнення фактично є ініціатива
дати пільгу ста діти війни якщо цей
статус буде включати стовідсоткове
забезпечення харчування дітей на місцеві
бюджети покладатися тільки для моєї
громади 102 млн грн ми просто не
витягнемо такі соціальні блага Я б
сказав більше навіть соціалістично
популістичні речі ми вже отримали такий
подарунок від Верховної Ради коли
звільнили в деокупованих територіях від
податку на нерухомість і земельного
податку 72 млн мінус відразу а за
рахунок якого ресурсу відновлювати тобто
коли ми говоримо про громади які
потребують певної уваги в силу специфіки
ведення військових дій без громад
ухвалювати рішення невірно неправильно
дякую
цю координацію і в тому числі між вашими
двома міністерствами тому що мені також
не очевидно А хто власник відповідає за
відновлення доступу до освіти
колеги дивіться моя треба знімати
навушники Я не розумію а ми дійсно
абсолютно згодні з тим що каже пан
Віталій школи і на це працювали реформи
децентралізації і так будувалися система
освіти реформи нової української школи
що мережу
ми бо він чітко розуміє де б це потрібно
де можна зробити підвезення і так далі
тому ми абсолютно підтримуємо Що це має
відбуватися на місцях дійсно є оце
момент хаосу в контексті Коли
з'являються там донорські кошти і Ми там
Ми достатньо така малий період часу
команда знаходимося в міністерстві і до
нас заходять багато Запитів там у нас
там там є така сума коштів нам треба дві
школи Нам треба одна школа нам треба
якась подібна історія і у них у всіх є у
кожного донора є певний свій набір
критеріїв нам там не можна цю область
тому що ми не хочемо наш донор не дасть
на цю область або давайте нам сюди і
дуже часто дійсно виникає питання що
чи наявне проектно-кошторисна
документація і чи бачимо ми взагалі що
це школа зруйнована на що ми
орієнтуємося сьогодні і ми з
координувались процес з міністерством
інфраструктури я не буду повну назву
Міністерства говорити Добре
а міністерство інфраструктури про те що
є реєстр пошкодженого зруйнованого майна
в які
обласні військові адміністрації вносять
дані і ми звідти беремо інформацію для
того щоб розуміти чи наявна зараз
проектна документація чи йдеться даний
об'єкт в якому стані ми дуже просимо
військ в обласній адміністрації вносити
туди ці дані тому що ми зараз окремо
збирали по окремій лінії дані по
зруйнованих закладах по Департаменту
освіти і в нас вийшли різниця півтори
тисячі закладів тобто вода нашим даним
3-400 по даним
міністерстві інфраструктури рпзм там
1980 закладів тобто Для нас це теж
важливо тому що ми допустимо навіть
викладені об'єктів на Юнайтед 24 школа
дійсно там є запит Що вона попало в
проект має бути наявна проектна
кошторисний документація так як
з'являються багато кейсів коли оціночна
вартість не відповідає
реальній потім донор не може
дофінансувати і в нас напів
недобудований об'єкт в результаті це теж
Я думаю Анна
прокомунікує зі свого боку коли вони
приймають рішення чи об'єкт виноситься
тобто з нашого боку є ми зараз
запустили разом зі світовим банком і
дісайдом процеси по
метінгу тобто щоб створити розуміння
який від залежності від факторів і
критеріїв тих громадах як допомогу тому
що в будь-якому випадку фінальне рішення
за громадою скільки має там бути шкіл і
так далі але ми хочемо зробити цей
інструмент щоб стратегічно допомагати
громаді визначати використовуючи таку
гнучку модель модель роботи тому я думаю
тут більше також скаже
Анна скажіть як цей трикутник місцева
навіть це такий квадрат чи прямокутник
не знає області громади мені відновлення
Іон Як це має працювати Так дякую дуже
гарне питання наша Міністерство було
фактично сформовано трішки більше ніж
Півроку назад коли постала
питання відбудову І фасилітації це всіх
процесів
після того як Міністерства було
сформоване Ми почали розбиратися хто з
донорів де працює деякі проекти І
наприклад в нас були досить такі
дивовижні речі коли які ми знаходили
наприклад там в Київській області Ми
знаходили об'єкти де прийшло туди три
донори на один об'єкт
освітній об'єкт тридомери за помітили і
підтвердили своє фінансування навіть
провели всю свою бюрократію і вже
вибрали підрядники 3 в той же час в нас
було маса просто сотні об'єктів ті же
Київській області буде взагалі нікого
немає немає жодного джерела і жодного
розуміння що взагалі з цими об’єктами
робити як туди прийти Ми почали цю
координацію для нас було основне те що
так Пропозиції бачення по закладах
освіти наприклад школа формують місцеві
органи влади да Ці пропозиції це бачення
має хтось верифікувати
і має подивитися і це стосується
закладів освіти закладів охорони
здоров'я будь-чого тобто в нас йде
ботома Петрович ми збираємо пропозиції
від місцевих органів влади потім в нас
сформовані методики є різні джерела і ми
маємо також розуміти що донори і навіть
вимоги нашого
внутрішньодержавного бюджетного
законодавства Вони мають свої певну
специфіку з певні вимоги один донор не
піде ближче ніж за 30 кілометрів до
лінії наприклад кордону з білоруссю чи
до лінії фронту другий донор не піде за
150 км до цієї лінії тобто є певна
специфіка один донор говорить дивіться
оце все добре вікна поміняти це добре чи
там щось пофарбувати ще краще але в нас
має бути проект пов'язаний з
енергоефективністю або в нас має бути
проект пов'язаний з ким то або специфіка
має бути така і ти вже збираєш іти
орієнтуєшся для того щоб
Скажімо так координувати цей хаос і
вивести його в якесь більш-менш
адекватне русло вже були прописані
методики пріоритезації і що ми зробили
ми також розробили систему Dream за
системалізованого управління відбудовую
і вже багато хто з вас подавав свої
проекти чи то для фінансування фонду
ліквідації чи в інші джерела через цю
систему Для того щоб ми могли бачити
карту де щоб покрито які ми джерелами і
коли ці об’єкти будуть відбудовані і чи
фінансуємо ми 5% від очікуваної вартості
об'єкта і ми розуміємо що цей об'єкт
ніколи не буде таким чином добудований
тому що ми просто дали
фінансування в нікуди чи ми фінансуємо
якісь комплексні проекти Анна Дякую
буквально на 2 хвилини залишається але
все ж поставлю це питання от в Італії
дуже правильно сказав в попередній
серіях що
треба думати про людей да а Ми багато
говоримо про заклади про інфраструктуру
вікна двері
енергоефективність А чи готові і
Міністерство освіти він відновлення
спільно з регіонами з тими які в першу
чергу постраждали звісно обговорювати
різні варіанти того як цих людей там
зберегти і відповідно це відображати в
своїх субвенціях Ну наприклад те що
казав пан Віталій про децентралізовані
освітні осередки Та от чи може це знайти
своє місце в наступному державному
бюджеті Я знаю що ви як держслужбовці
політичного рівня не можете нічого
обіцяти проте все ж
щоб обговорюється принаймні таке
чи готові ви це обговорювати не знаю Я
думаю що це стоїть сьогодні в будь-якому
випадку в порядку денному в першу чергу
з донорами великими
гуманітарними юнісе все the children про
це багато йде розмови про створення
таких тимчасових осередків для
надання освітніх послуг на рівні держави
ми подаємо пропозиції зараз відбувається
бюджетний процес і ми в тому числі
подаємо до розгляду свої пропозиції щодо
підтримки подібних рішень тобто від нас
такі пропозиції зараз йдуть ми будемо
робити все можливе для того щоб в
обмежених умовах та наступного року бо
бюджет наступного року буде великим
викликом для України Я думаю що про це
пан Віталій коментар і тоді на
завершення попрошу кожного з наших
спікерів сказати буквально кілька
булоктів Що на вашу думку має змінитися
у підході до відновлення або Наступного
року ми поговорили вже з вами трішечки
кращому контексті Я хочу попросити
Міністерство освіти підготуйте увагу як
основний чи центральний - це дитячий
тому що там мама батькам треба працювати
в тому числі на нашу перемогу школи
можуть навчатися онлайн змішано Думати
бо вони самостійні більш-менш діти
дошкільного возраста Ні і це основна
проблема щоби люди працювали створювали
додатковувану вартість та податки це
перше і друга профтехосвіта тому що це
потрібні нам люди щоб вони працювали на
відбудову нашої держави ці питання йдуть
на загал А я хотів би щоб вони були
пріоритетним хоча б для постраждалих
регіонів Дуже дякую Я припускаю що це
власне те що має змінитися в підході до
відновлення або додатися П Анатолію вашу
думку продовження діалогу діалог існує
по другому не відновлювали наші регіони
міста між міністерством і освіти і
міністерством розвитку інфраструктури
теж укорочена назва будуть говорити
треба змінити цю назву таку довгу і саме
таким чином ми досягаємо результату Але
разом з тим виходячи із специфіки яка
існує ми розуміємо що система має бути
більш гнучкішою і більш чіткішою в
реалізації часових рамків тому що
безпекові питання в Миколаєві і одні а
Бучі в Київському регіоні зовсім інші
тут треба враховувати Дякую Вікторія
Я думаю що нам потрібно випрацьовувати
Ось такі системні підходи типу там де
можна знайти типовим проектом з певними
варіаціями треба йтиповим там де можна
робити загальні ну тобто держава має
робити певну рамку і гайдлайн і по
відновленню саме яка якість очікується
від цього відновлення і вже тоді громади
як замовники цього мають користуватися
цим планом і самостійно його втілювати
це Перше А друге - це ну і відповідно те
що ми робимо по школах така ж сама
історія по дитсадочках абсолютно
ідентична а друге - це Чого мені
здається зараз не вистачає Ну наприклад
ми помічаємо в нашому процесі це те що
ця комунікація між монами і інфра і її
дійсно дуже мало І має бути відношення
до освітян як до Ну я вам кажу що бачив
має бути відношення до сміття як до
клієнта
Тобто ми не просто відбудовуємо щоб
відбудувати А ми відбудовуємо для кого і
що саме І що що ти по цим людям потрібно
якщо ми говоримо про реформу нуш Який
запит нуш На новій освітній простори
дошкільні простори про втехи і так далі
Дякую Євгена і Анна останній короткий
коментарі Анну почнемо з вас і Євген як
ми можемо пожартувати про нашу
комунікацію але але не не при тому я
думаю що за цей рік трішки менше Коли
фактично хоч якась відбудова в державі
почалась ми винесли певні уроки ми
винесли як держава ми як місцеві органи
влади ми як донори і певні уроки
винесені і будемо покращувати але для
нас як для Міністерства відновлення буде
надзвичайно корисним якщо ми в певний
момент почнемо з вами говорити тут Я
підтримую абсолютно Віталія кімо про про
тих освіту тому що це те Без чого в нас
відбудова не буде це абсолютно величезна
кількість спеціалізацій Це абсолютно ми
розуміємо що на відбудову прийдуть і дай
Бог її іноземний бізнес іноземні
компанії місцеві компанії будуть
розвиватися і так далі але це людський
капітал хто це фактично І що
відбудовувати Тому Дякую Анна чекаємо на
субвенції в новому держбюджеті Женю
у нас однозначно в пріоритеті сьогодні
дошкілля і професійна освіта вперше за
довгий час є окремий заступник який
відповідає і за професійну освіту і за
дошкілля ну різні це дві різні людини і
професійна освіта в пріоритеті і в
програмі президента і ми зрозуміємо про
те що відбудова і відновлення це дуже
комплексний процес і ми маємо зрозуміти
який принципи Там будуть і зараз
міністерство інфраструктури робить
важливі зміни в системі Dream і будуть
оновлені підходи в тому числі для
відслідковування що відбувається в сфері
освіти по-іншому тому ми дуже важливо
щоб ми мали цей постійний трьохсторонній
контакт так як в будь-якому випадку
заклади належать органи місцевого
самоврядування від нас задача розуміння
як змінюється реформи як змінюється ЗМІ
які як підтримати вчителів тому що для
того щоб в цих регіонах була інша
підтримка вчителів треба змінити і
підходи і в оплаті праці і в навчанні
педагогів Зараз ми відновлюємо субвенцію
для нової української школи найближчими
тижнями вона буде прийнята вже Кабінетом
міністрів і 5-6 класи зможуть отримати
обладнання то це цілісні речі і
відновлення воно стосується абсолютно
всіх Я думаю тут спільними зусиллями ми
дійсно зможемо це зробити вже найближчим
часом Дякую Сьогодні сподіваюсь люди це
відчують бо це найголовніше я всім Дуже
дякую за участі і тим хто нас слухав І
тим хто висидів цю годину дякую
дякуємо
добре Ми отримали підтвердження від
нашої групи технічно що ми можемо
розпочинати і я вас всіх вітаю на нашій
панелі про Обговорення відновлені та
відбудови система освіти в Україні і
наразі
дуже багато наших друзів з нами нас Яке
Який раз З нами З Юнеско з нами далі
Андрій губар директор програми
з нами теж онлайн
і в нас
також голова
аналогічної програми з нами онлайн і
штаб штефан-штройн це голова
євроделегації в Україні які також для
нас для нас приєднався онлайн В нас є
сіль є від проун з нами він офлайн Віра
міндон який головою з в Україні
відділення нас є
заступник голови від фонду
сейврон і я Всіх вітаю тут для нас ця
дійсно особлива тема тому що те що ми
маємо Наразі це дійсно неперевершена
підтримка від міжнародної спільноти
і ця підтримка допомагає нам
вистояти і також
поточній ситуації
це підтримка зокрема відновлення
відбулось займи дійсно довгий час до
того ж ми зважаючи на ці втрати яких ми
вже потерпаємо і це дійсно те що
вибудовує відновлення йдеться про наші
мрії про можливість відновлення українця
проблема яка потребує комплексного
рішення і об'єднання всіх зусиль тому Ми
наразі сьогодні і намагаємося відтворити
навіть
якомога ефективніше співробітництва і
всі організації які наразі нас присутні
і які долучилися і Вже долучилися до нас
їх дуже багато і вони вкладаються не
тільки у відновленні та Але й в і
основна частина яка якій тут схоче
наголосити це коли ви вводите ставити
запитання то я би дуже був вдячний якщо
ви поділилися не тільки власним досвідом
про те і вашими думками на майбутнє
вашої візою те що ви робите ваших
проектах ваші пріоритети і також наші
секції ми пропонуємо зокрема обговорити
контекст відновлення та відбудови в
нашому галузі освіти чому це важливо
тому що ви фактично представляєте дійсно
от потужні великі організації і ця
неоцінила роль та вклад ваших
організацій це
я би скажімо ви є створюєте такі канали
об'єднання зорями організаціями таких
проектах і тому Які ваші пріоритети Яка
ваша вісі і Як ваша організація
вкладається в
відтворенні цих пріоритетів і скажімо чи
дійсно вияві відслідковуєте ці
пріоритети Як ви визначаєте до
коркострокові довгострокові цілі
це для нас було дійсно цінним почути як
ви погоджуєте ваші пріоритети тобто ваша
організація з майбутнього України хто
будь ласка з вас готовий будь ласка
пропонуємо
Віра будь ласка
перш за все Я хочу сказати що
ініціатива дуже чудова тому що в нас
зібралися більш ніж 700 вчителів і наших
колег - Це дійсно надихає і я знаю що це
наше таке зібрання
об'єднує тих вчителів які наразі
перебувають і вкриттях і ми обговорюємо
потреби освіти для нас юнісеф для наш
нашої пріоритети ми керуємось таким
керівництвом перш за все по відновленню
також плану уряду і також політикою та
реформами в освіті які вже уряд у країні
розпочав ще до війни це забезпечує Що
будь-що ми робимо буде дійсно
реагуванням на гуманітарні потреби на
підтримку візи уряду в плані дійсно
трансформація для перебудови системи
освіти в коли ми говоримо про нашу візію
нісеф з співпраці в уряді це перш за все
щоб кожна дитина включається підлітків
дійсно могла розвивати свої навички і
надбання для майбутнього і також ми
фокусуємося на перш на трьох областях
перше - це
скажімо зміцнення в цілому систему
освіти і перш за все це повернення наших
інвестицій того що ми вкладаємо в
систему освіти і надання
кожній дитині
доброго майбутнього перш за все це
безпечне середовище і ми говоримо тут не
тільки про
мав на увазі навчальне середовище це не
тільки
укриття проте ці можливості в рамках
громади для того щоб підтримати в цілому
і також підтримка підлітків це Полі
їхніх навички надання і можливостей для
долучення в цьому до процесу і розвитку
власних здібностей і ще що ми робимо
тому що ми працюємо в багатьох секторах
це перш за все багато секторний підхід і
ми також зважаємо на потреби громад це і
цифрове навчання і
також цілі дитини та батьків на майбутнє
далі ми працюємо з громадою і ми
розглядаємо різні потреби в різних
областях перш за все тих областях які
найближчі до лінії фронту Ми більше
спираємось на онлайн навчання тому що
ясно що офлайн дуже складно Також ми
намагаємось віднайти можливість для
впровадження цих опцій локальних
громадах і також це
індивідуальне навчання і в будь-яких
менітетах те що ми робимо це той підхід
який перш за все знову ж таки розвиває
і створює сталу модель проте і включаючи
різні методології та моделі онлайн
навчання формальні та неформальне
навчання тих тобто
позашкільного навчання і виховання і
також тому що ми перш за все наші
основні драйвер це знання це перш за все
скажімо це документація адвокація для
того щоб діти настояла У фокусі цього
процесу відновлення та відбудови тому що
коли ми зводимо партнерів разом і
намагаємось координувати і так щоб
дійсно фінансово використовувались
ефективно це перш за все і кластерна в
координація секторальна підтримка і
координація платформи це скажімо різні
діяльності які ми розглядаємо і побудова
структури
так Сирена Чи можете ви поділитися
вашими пріоритетами та досвідом Дякую
перш за все хочу доєднатися до Віра вже
сказала перш за все
у нас в рамках фонду сейвса це перш за
все для нас кожна дитина Тобто ми якби
будуємо візи для кожної дитини щоб
дитина спокійно безпечно вижила
навчалась і це ми робимо вже від початку
14-го року в Україні і в освіті все що
ми робимо це підтримка дітей вчителів
садків шкіл
на будь-якому рівні навчання
і намагаючись захистити перш за все
права дітей на якісну освіту і від
вересня Минулого року ми
поширили нашу активність наразі Ми
підтримуємо
освіту більш ніж 50 тисяч дітей Ми також
захищаємо права дитини на як основну
освіту і в плані наші
короткострокових цілей та пріоритетів це
перш за все
ось що мені приходить безпосередньо на
думку це безпека дітей та вчителів перш
за все це в нас Наш пріоритет поточний
так щоб ми включали в діяльність перш за
все захист дітей
це
[музика]
скажімо перебудова та обладнання
укриттів безпечних для вчителів та учнів
щоб вони могли продовжити процес
навчання і Ми віримо що діти краще
навчаються коли вони разом разом з
вчителями разом зі своїми друзями і тому
ми вкладаємось в промоції
ідеї безпеки безпечних просторів які
дозволяють дітям разом навчатися ми
робимо через цифрові центри навчання А і
наразі ми вже відкрили 10 центрів які
дозволяють вчителям та учням
продовжувати на їхній навчальний процес
разом обмінюватися думками тобто що це
було
емоціональне середовище
безпечними також підтримуємо які
наприклад втратили школи там де було
зруйновані школи або неможливо
забезпечити безпеку знову ж таки
викриттях це створення укриття для щоб
того щоб діти все ж таки продовжили
навчатися разом і також базова підтримка
вже в локаціях де вже є стабільні
структури наразі і коли ми поглядаємо
наперед ми
залучаємо та підтримуємо
скажімо Ось такі
мультидисциплінарних партнерів в плані
навчання так щоб
чітко було ясно хто що вкладається І
об'єднати ці зусилля і перш за все ми
хочемо забезпечити щоби оце відновлені
та відбудова Так це є пріоритетом проте
все ж таки потрібно забезпечити
навчальний процес як інклюзивний процес
саме щоб не одна дитина не випала з
цього процесу і тому якісне навчання
перш за все має бути впроваджено щоби
незалежно від того ти де вчинив
знаходиться вона отримувала ту ж саму
якість навчання і тому ми намагаємося
спроектувати ось таку систему ще де діти
знаходять які знаходяться в найбільш
розвиненому становище щоб дійсно для них
створити безпечне середовище дякую
і тепер хочу надати слово Стефано і хочу
попросити Чи можете викреслити скажімо
такі загальні перспективи в плані
освіти в Україні і можете ви нам
показати дійсно
як це буде документовано як буде
спроектована на майбутнє як це буде в
цілому і для системи
освіти майбутнього в Україні Що ви
будете вкладатися Якщо ви будете
вкладатися в перспективі все дякую дякую
колеги Дякую друзі сподіваюсь що ви мене
добре чуєте
я можу приєднатися до вас тільки
дистанційно тому що дійсно
програма мови візиту дуже така Щільна де
10 днів тому вовків проти наразі вже
прийшлось від'їхати і дійсно ради
приєднатися до вас онлайн з боку
Європейського Союзу що я можу сказати
так скажімо в двох словах
те що ми робимо із
збираємось робити в майбутньому для того
щоб підтримати Україну на шляху до
Євросоюзу і те що ми пропонуємо Ми дуже
багато ще багато років працюємо в цілому
в сфері освіти як і в плані політики так
і
практичному вимірі на
місцях
я маю на увазі на рівні школи на рівні
інфраструктури для того щоб
переобладнати школи також первинний і
вторинної ланки освіти і також
професійної освіти і підготовки і також
ми працюємо з університетами з вишами
намагаємось поширити цю програму далі
охопити студентів
того щоб
вони росли розвивались і освіта дійсно
це
скажімо важлива справа проте скажімо
можу сказати що це дійсно це ключова
галузь в плані відновлення відбудови і
так дальше всім нам ясно що без
успішних зусиль в секторі освіти
загальне відновлення України
скажімо не вдасться я би так сказав
перш за все це має бути доступ до освіти
це ключовий момент в цілому проте також
той момент що
тут не
зазначено Ключовим фактором і з
економічної перспективи і економічного
зростання
це ключовий елемент особливо для
прийняття рішень зокрема для
громадян України для їхнього повернення
до України в плані чи будуть мати їхні
діти Коли вони повернуться в Україну
доступ до якісної освіти і це ключовий
елемент і тому
дискусія
продовжується стосовно
інструментів яких потрібно залучити щоб
опрацювати все і мій колега приїжджає в
Україну на цьому тижні і я сподіваюсь що
він також продовжиться обговорення за
колегами Зоряну як ми говорили вже про
плани Україні які будуть закладати
основу для майбутнього і також для наших
інструментів І звісно що основний меседж
це українського плану це документ має
бути створений документ
розроблений урядом в ході консультації
слідства
громадським суспільством
І звісно
ми як Євросоюз ключовий партнер і інші
ключові партнери Я маю на увазі Світовий
банк
і також всі країни-члени і фінансові
інституції всі основні та важливі
клієнти тобто партнери їхня роль тут не
може бути переоціненою І звісно
рішення за урядом звісно які
пріоритети зазначити стратегії і ми
дійсно заважаємо на те що у світі має
бути нада найважливіша роль і
план звісно України базується перш за
все на відбудові економіці з продатися
має бути
захоплюючі план як і то
реабілітації і відновлення і
суми інфраструктури і також шкільної
інфраструктури як то садків шкіл
і так далі І це має бути чітко прописано
в плані і це тоді поставити освіту
дійсно фокус уваги на майбутнє тому що
перш за все це буде
50 мільярдів євро буде надано Це дійсно
просто
неперевершений тобто
такий рівень фінансування для країни
якого поки що навіть не було серед
країн-членів і сподіваємося що це
дійсно
відновить
такі
чіткі і важливі зміни для того щоб
поліпшити в Україні і вступ до ЄС і оці
міліції в євро це буде в комбінації з
прямою підтримкою країни щодо бюджету і
підтримки інвестиції і також технічна
підтримка на локальному рівні компаніям
консультаційним організаціям і урядовим
і наразі будь ласка слово вам
Чи можете мене чути Зараз
у мене таке запитання до вас А стосовно
бачення світового банку Можливо ви
можете це якось пов'язати з
перспективами економічного розвитку
а також інші факт іншими факторами які є
підтвердженням економічного зросту
і які забезпечать
зростання чи розвиток
сфери освіти
я звичайно з вами погоджуюсь це все дуже
пов'язано з іншими факторами такими як
благополуччя
суспільства також
розвиток такий компетевний
ми говоримо про велику кількість людей
мені я навіть дуже хотіла би бути з вами
сьогодні тут
і
поділитися і більш детально тими
ініціативами якими
робимо ті діяльності яку ми робимо в
сфері освіти
Отож відомо що Світовий банк надає
підтримку фінансу
розвитку також це діяльність буде
продовжуватись
ми розуміємо що я дуже серйозний
глибокий
потреби в Україні для того щоб
забезпечити те щоб вчителі продовжували
навчати
тому ми говоримо і про середню освіту
про вищу освіту
Нам необхідно забезпечити послідовність
навчання перехід до вищого світу тому ми
ведемо перемовини
з нашими партнерами в Європі і мова йде
про сотні мільйонів доларів підтримки
для того щоб
підвищити спроможність
але доводиться нам зараз балансувати
нашу підтримку з підтримкою
українського уряду
Ми також займаємося наданням технічної
підтримки
і працюємо в різноманітних
сферах наприклад надання
освіти онлайн та деталізації освіти і
також оптимізації цих процесів Ми також
підтримуємо
в той же час ми
проводимо оцінку
того що наразі відбувається в сфері
освіти в Україні Ми намагаємося оцінити
як ту шкоду яка була завдана в цій сфері
також постійно проводимо оцінку потреб
і ми визначили кількість
закладів освіти котрі були зруйновані
котрі потребують допомоги з відбудовою
з тих пір я так розумію що кількість ці
цифри збільшилися
і потреби відповідно також збільшувалася
відновлені
але відновлення сфери освіти передбачає
значно більше ніж відновлення
закладів зруйнованих будівель закладів
освіти
необхідне додаткове фінансування для
навчання вчителів для покращення їх
професійності
і ми на це також звертаємося увагу
відшукуємо партнерів з якими ми могли б
сприяти
покращенню та відновлення а також
обладнання котре необхідної для освіти
для навчання
я
Так ми вже поговорили про відбудову
інфраструктуру і говорили про цифри 9
мільярдів котрі вже призначені на
відбудову
будівель закладів народної освіти
і буде але це не остаточна допомога ще
буде додатково виділена і затверджена
додаткова сума
і також ми
продовжувати мого інвестувати в людській
капітал людський ресурси Дуже дякуємо
керен Я хотів би
звернутися до Кіри і запит і запитати
вас Чи не могли б поділитися своїм
досвідом
щодо
тих
проектів котрі зараз відбувається в
Україні
щодо відновлення і як ви бачите
майбутнє цього сектора а також бачення
Юнеско з цього приводу
Дуже дякую за можливість
відповісти на це запитання я вам як ми
ви знаєте
іноско є
парасольковою структурою для оцих усіх
ініціатив і
бачення Юнеско полягає в тому що
і всі діти і дорослі мають право і
доступ до отримання якісного освіти
без
будь-яких винятків включаючи навіть
найбільш вразливі категорії
учнів чи бажають їх отримати освіту
а її наше бачення
повністю гармонізоване з
цілями розвитку
ООН
і ми говоримо не тільки про якість
освіти Ми також говоримо про
бачення України щодо розвитку освіти
щодо стратегії то наші пріоритети такі
два пріоритети
а надання
допомоги для того щоб задовольнити
негайні потреби у відбудові а також
підготовка
підґрунтя для
подальшого розвитку і відновлення
що стосується пріоритетів
Юнеско
також має чотири
пріоритети щодо
розвитку освіти
стосовно Ми співпрацюємо з міністерством
освіти
і вони були озвучені на нашому сьомому
зібранні чи зустрічі і отож перша
пріоритет - це доступ до постійного
поступового навчання
також розробка програмного забезпечення
для забезпечення
якісного навчання
для того щоб освіта могла якісно
надаватися онлайн
і цей компонент є важливий
і ми велике значення
цифрові трансформації наприклад
більше 50 тисяч різноманітних приладів
були надані системі освіти України для
мети дечиталізації освіти звичайно на в
першу чергу чи цікавить якість і
розбудова спроможності
і і наші пріоритети вони також
підтримують і батьків і вчителів і
співробітників міністерств
Ми також приділяємо значення
здатності адаптуватися і до змінячихся
обставин і ми тут поговоримо як про
вчителів так і про учнів
дуже часто самі вчителі виявляються не
готовими до кризових ситуацій і ми
навчати проводимо тренінги для
стресостійкості до
формуємо здатність до адаптуватися до
змін
і ми зараз говоримо
в про вчителів і про різноманітні
проблеми з котрими вони можуть стикатися
один
наших проектів буде розпочинатися в
жовтні і аудиторією стануть 50 тисяч
вчителів
ми будемо
навчати педагогічним навичкам
з психосоціальній підтримці
А нещодавно ми також розпочали
разом з міністерством
ми навчали більше 100 тисяч А психологів
з різноманітних регіонів України і ці
психологи зараз
починають проводити
тренінги самостійно
розповсюджувати ці знання і навички далі
для формування компетенцій для того щоб
надавати психосоціальну підтримку дітям
психологічну підтримку в школах також Ми
займаємося
реабілітацією оскільки вважаємо що це
дуже важливий аспект з точки зору
Юнеско
Отож ми підтримуємо
зусилля і послуги реабілітації
також сприяємо тому щоби
середовище освітнє було
включним щоб всі мали доступ незалежно
від обставин
тому ми працюємо разом з урядом України
розробляємо пакети послуг і в першу
чергу ми підтримуємо національну систему
підтримкою а також
увагу звертаємо на
довгострокові цілі
Отож ми підтримуємо Міністерство
Працюємо з міністерством
базуємо наші зусилля На твердих наукових
фактах і обставинах про котрий ми
дізнаємося
Ми намагаємося
сприяти тому щоби цей розвиток був
сталим
я не буду говорити про різноманітні види
діяльності в деталях про які Ми
займаємося але й більше 100 тисяч
студентів наразі є цільовою аудиторією
програмою ЮНЕСКО в Україні
і Отож ми будемо займатися цим ми її
надалі будемо
співпрацювати з освітньою спільноти Дуже
дякую керен У мене є також інше
запитання до вас
Отож Ви працюєте
напряму з місцевими спільнотами
втілюєте програм Ви також працюєте з
європейською комісією У вас є
різноманітний досвід у ваших програмної
діяльності
Чи можете поділитися власним баченням та
викликами Як ви їх бачите в Україні щоб
ви порадили українській спільноті щоб ви
порадили міжнародним донорам
як Які ваші пріоритети дуже Дякую це
дуже приємно бути тут разом з вами
я дуже
вражений і не тільки
здатністю адаптуватися України до змін
та до
в результаті
втручання Росії
але я також бачу що
дуже радий бачити
як усі оті зусилля які зараз
докладаються для того щоб зробити
українську освіту ще кращою ще надійніше
як я вже і казав Ми допомагаємо з
розбудовою зруйнованих скул також з
реабілітацією Ми також
більше ніж зі сотнею шкіл ми працюємо
відбудовуємо їх оці руйнування котрі
трапилося не тільки в результаті війни а
також
по причині інших факторів тому що
школи мають поновлюватися вони мають
ставати більш сучасними і
європейське і інвестиційний банк нам
допомагає з цією розбудовою
і тому
ми розробили підход спільний
визначила сфери котрі потребують
інвестування і у нас принципи починаючи
від інклюзивного включаючого і відводи
до
до покращення доступ щоб кожен мав
легкий доступ навіть діти з інвалідністю
з якимись особливостями спеціальними
потребами і також ми
намагаємося
сприяти тому щоб оці будівлі були
ефективними з точки зору споживання
енергії а
також щоб вони були більш зеленими і а
це також дуже важлива робота і вона буде
займати не місяці а більше в роки
Тобто ми використовуємо дуже велике
значення приділяємо принцип у зеленому
принципу а також ми намагаємося зробити
ці школи і новативними новими сучасними
практичними ефективними щоб вони
були
ефективнішими як для вчителів так і для
учнів і ми дуже віддані цій роботі і як
я вже сказав ми працюємо з 150 школами і
в Одесі і в Харкові в Миколаєві а також
в Закарпатті ми працюємо і в Житомирі
всі ці школи є дуже важливими для нас і
ми також
щільно співпрацюємо з міністерством
освіти
Але не тільки ми залучені до
середовище шкіл Ми також проводимо
дослідження у сфері освіти
також генетичні дослідження проводимо
в світові банки є нашим партнером в цій
роботі а також
ми вивчали ефективність професійного
навчання наскільки воно є ефективним
і наскільки
освітня система допомагає і ефективною
на шляху учнів до вступу до вищих
навчальних закладів Тобто ми проводимо
таку національну велику національне
дослідження
і я коротко поділюся
результатами
по котрі полягають в тому що більше ніж
більше і більше
учнів починають Приймати участь у
різноманітних
діяльності стають активістами
намагаються сприяти тому щоби учні мали
кращий доступ до послуг навчання А також
те що учні стають мають кращу здатність
до адаптації ніж раніше
Отож ви зробили дуже багато зусилля на
шляху дечиталізації в Україні а також
децентралізації освіти Я розумію що у
вас є свої пріоритети у ваших проектів
Що на вашій повісті наразі є головнішим
вашій роботі
ми вас чуємо чи не чуємо Ні поки що не
чуємо
перевірте будь ласочка ваш мікрофон
бо ми вас не чуємо
будь ласка скажіть щось щоби ми вас
почути А у наразі ми вас чуємо добре
добре
бо я вас не чую
Добренько тепер ми вас чуємо А ви мене
тепер чуєте Так ми вас чуємо
добре вибачаюсь за затримку
і ось чому краще дійсно бути особисто
ніж використовувати
онлайн інструменти я на наступного тижня
до вас приєднаюся проте і розумію що
щоб ти наразі з вами Мені потрібно
приєднатися одне добре Я скажу декілька
слів сподіваюсь що всі мене чують так
тому що я бачу люди кивають головами що
ви мене чуєте будь ласка покайте
головами якщо ви мене чуєте Так ми
бо Дехто з онлайн мене не чує
Ну добре
ну Швейцарія вже давно підтримує
процес децентралізації в Україні Ми вже
декілька проектів зробили ми
підтримували Міністерство і
Софії органи самоврядування і для того
щоб дійсно зробити роботу більш
ефективною і ми дійсно віримо що освітні
сектори освіти це є передумовою це тим
фактором які дійсно
видає дуже велику роль розбудові
суспільства те що я бачив іноді коли Ми
подорожуємо Я бачив різницю коли я
відвідував школу в Києві наприклад і в
школу особистого віддалених районах це
було різниця перший момент другий момент
і для нас дещо нове коли наприклад
порівняти з тим що ми мали два роки тому
в плані
безпосередніх та довгострокових потреб
Звісно що все це змінюється наразі тепер
ми будуємо укриття бо вони потрібні і ми
відслідковуємо цей процес тому що наразі
це дуже велика потреба проте ясно що ми
не будемо вбудовувати укриття в наш
підхід і перш за все це відновлення яке
відбудова І так я розумію що це має йти
через
загальним процесом відбудови і це
фактично якби ДНК нашого проекту і наша
найважливіша ціль - це стати дійсно
рушійною силою української економіки для
її відновлення безпосередньо І дійсно
ось
відновити кращі Це дійсно це основний
принцип принцип і це є фундаментальний
принцип в рамках нашої ініціативи
відновлення Як ви говорите українського
відбудова і ясно що це не тільки
відбудова шкіл та навчання це перш за
все буде базуватися локально для того
щоб дійсно створити ось такий власність
цього процесу на місцевому рівні це не
тільки
відновити краще бо відновити разом і
перебудувати і для цього проекту перш за
все це посилення місцевого потенціалу
місцевого врядування для того щоб вони
долучилися активно до процесу відбудови
і також це іноцінний підхід і пережив
все і освіти як і освітнього персоналу і
залучити
студентів
учнів до цього процесу можливо це вже не
нове проте все ж таки з новішої по тому
що Ми віримо що діти учні не мають бути
залучені до процесу прийняття рішень
Вони мають відчувати що вони є
громадянами майбутнього і тому всі ці
діяльності в цілому це якраз і побудова
і розбудова кращих принципів автош
кращого відновлення Як ви і говорите
Дякую вам дякую і в нас останній спікер
на нашій панелі Анна васад у вас дійсно
дуже великий досвід
в соціальних проектах проектах
відновлення і тепер ви розвиваєте центри
цифрового навчання ви відновлюєте доступ
до навчання робите фактично навчання
можливим для того щоби дійсно
впроваджувати забезпечувати права на
навчання Ви працюєте з донероз
Міжнародним організаціями ви фактично
представляєте місцеві Ну та
міжнародні ЗНО я впевнені теж буде
представляти про які в вас ваш власний
досвід Як ви збираєтесь впроваджувати ці
проекти в Україні і я купив підтримку на
яку підтримку ви можете розраховувати
від міжнародних ЗНО та міжнародних
партнерів в Україні
Дякую Вітаю всіх Я дуже рада тут бути з
вами на цей панелі і так ми працюємо для
того щоб відновити доступ до навчання і
відповідно поведете в на суспільство ми
все робимо за останні вже десь рік
зокрема
у північних областях після звільнення ми
знаємо що там Росія звернула практично
кожну школу і ось на жаль
ми маємо з цим справу базучись на моєму
досвіді і в цілому
співпраці з міністерством Міжнародним
партнерами
можливо тут хочу знати декілька моментів
перш за все дуже важлива що всі партнери
і нас на ми звісно щоб ми перш за все
розуміла контекст контекст дійсно
різниця по всій Україні тому що якщо
говорити в цілому про стратегію України
в цілому то ми маємо знати що
відбувається Миколаївській області
Харківській області які стан який стан
Київській області А це все дуже різний
контекст на жаль
так декілька місцевих громад в Києві
дуже постраждали інші не так постраждали
і якщо ви хочете відновити навчання то
ви маєте знати які ми є місцевий
контекст На жаль наприклад
а в Київській області практично
більшості місцях по можна повне вістю
відмовити і та про те через ракетні
обстріли деякі школи були зруйновані тим
не менше ось наприклад в Житомирі де
місцева рада фактично фізично відновлює
інфраструктуру ми відновлюємо доступ і
щоб можна було відкачати нове навчальний
рік А ось на Миколаївській області Це
абсолютно інша історія там практично
немає сенсу відбудовувати поки що школи
тому що там небезпечна взагалі
перебувати та навчатися і нам потрібно
уявити собі Як це зробити і це дійсно
виходить за
фактичну стратегію
яку прийнято день іншої частини країни в
рамках конфлікту Я не знаю як це дійсно
включити в цю всю загальну стратегію про
це дуже важливо як
зробити для міжнурих партнерів То
наприклад перш за все ось цей фон цей
вже childing так Це дуже добре ми це був
наш перший партнер до того як ми маєте
почали існувати ми зробили з ними
цифрові центри цифрового освіти фактично
ми почали рости через цю ініціативу
створюючи тимчасові школи на той момент
і це були єдині
ціни де можна було відновити навчальний
процес а тоді як в Миколаївській області
Ми вже
розпочали працювати і дякуючи
інструментам ми вже зробили
я не буду Перелічити ці адреси цих
локації про те ось разом з Віталієм
кимом який я якраз головою то
Миколаївській області ми віднайшли ці
місця які будуть безпечні для дітей які
можна навчатиме місце в маленьких групах
і
це фактично нерегулярне навчання но хоча
б це буде краще ніж взагалі нічого і ось
цих причин бо ми всі розуміємо що
Протягом цього року
Росія також буде обстрілювати школи сили
спрямовано як ми бачили Це в Сумах що
вони поцілили в школу сели спрямовано
тому що там не було ніяких солдатів
ніхто не розташовується ні в школах ні в
садках і особливо
скажімо там все було 4 особи тоді
знаходились в школі вони постраждали і
ясно що Росія буде це продовжувати таку
справу з іншої сторони
діти не можуть залишатися вдома до
самого кінця війни і потрібно віднайти
які швидкі рішення і це нас приводить до
питання того що Ну я не знаю як про те
ми маємо бути дуже гнучкими І звісно все
ж таки є бюрократія і Міжнародне
бюрократія яка досить таки довго
спрацьовує про те ми маємо Ось і
українська також бюрократія є про те ось
останній
весни через те що Росія то що ми бачили
із усією буде те ж саме цією осені Росія
буде цілитися в школи і тому відновлення
дійсно воно необхідне проте воно буде
різне і не сприймайте це як образу тобто
цій війні
Україна більш за все потерпає і про те
ясно що ми знаємо що звільнена не буде
настільки швидким як і буде перше
звільнення Харківської області в 22-му
році і тепер фактично фокуси зміщуються
Ну я не знаю
фактично війна наш стає фактично
частиною нашого буття і ми знаємо що ми
всі разом не можемо допустити щоби це
дійсно дуже сильно спливало на нашу
Дякуємо а не
ну нас залишилось дві хвилини на
завершення нашої дискусії Я знаю дуже
добре
Всі ваші плани скільки скажімо часу ви
вкладаєте і зусиль вкладаєте Звісно що
ви є друзями України майбутнього Чи
можете ви сказати якісь мотиваційні
слова для тих хто нас наразі слухає вони
нас слухають і Вони думають
майбутнє щоб ви могли їм порекомендувати
що має бути зроблено в плані
розвитку
майбутнього світу в Україні
і будь ласка буквально
дві фрази від кожного І ми завершуємо
нашу панель будь ласка розпочинаємо з
сирени
добре Сподіваюся мене чуєте так
Ну я б сказала щоби ми всі залишалися
відданими відданими справі тому що
освіта - це довгостроковий процес і він
займає час і ми маємо дійсно бути
відданими продовжувати підтримувати
освіту в Україні і це значить що ми
маємо бути готовими до всіх викликів
які ми зустрінемо на нашому шляху і
маємо бути ми тому вмотивованими і ось
від фонду сейф the children Давайте
зробимо так щоби Діти теж долучилися до
цієї
дискусії Для нас це дуже важливо щоби
діти також були частиною
процесу прийняття рішень тому що ці
рішення стосуються фактичної їхнього
життя та й переваг в їхньому житті і
тому я всіх закликаю всіх думати про
майбутнє дітей і долучати дітей Віра я
перш за все хочу висловити велику подяку
всім вчителям які продовжуються
підтримати освіту в Україні
продовжується працював в таких складних
умовах ми дійсно
готові і слухати ваші голоси тому що
ваші голоси це те що вартує для
майбутнього і на регіональному на
локальному рівнях всі Я сподіваюсь що
всі урядо організації будуть
підтримувати особливо це відновлення
інфраструктури тому що інвестиції
настільки важливі всіх наших партнерів І
тому ми маємо пріоритезувати
і буквально локальні партнери продумайте
як куди їх спрямовувати ці ресурси які
дуже важливі і також ще раз Хочу
висловити велику подяку і пошану всі
вчителям які працюють на своїх ланках і
дякую вам за таку Прекрасну конференцію
Добре тепер перейдемо до наших
онлайн-партнерів так щоб ми теж
висловилися Кіра будь ласка
скажіть вашу мотиваційну рекомендації
для наших слухачів Я б сказала
об'єднуватися з колегами це має бути
Довіра співпраця всіх нас разом це
найважливіше це фундаментальний такий
підхід і я
зустрічалась з багатьма вчителями
це десь вже рік
моєї праці в Україні і тому освіта
дійсно потребує інвестицій не тільки від
одної людини про те від цих нас від всій
нашої громади і ми маємо продовжувати це
робити Дякуємо Андреас
Ну як же це означали
зазначали так і тому я хочу всіх
заохотити щоб ми всі діти дотримувалися
дійсно шляху нашого скажімо і
дійсно якось справлялися Тобто
всі ці бюрократичні перепони проходили
щоб нам нічого не втратити це перше
по-друге як я вже зазначав щоб ми всі
були разом тому що скажімо це і
центральна на локальному
рівні і місцевих моментів і міжнародна
спільнота щоб ми всі були разом і
працювали для дітей дякую андреюся
наразі Інна Ну в принципі мене більше
все мотивує це звільнення території
особливо там де повзнів порушений процес
освіти Дякуємо Яна
будь ласка
ось коли я бачив оці дійсно наскільки
молоді
людивованими і їхнє натхнення
то її Ви знаєте це ось цей принцип
давайте відновлений якнайкраще це
фактично те ж саме
в маємо перш за все
підходити до того чого ми навчаємо наших
дітей що ми вкладаємо їхні голови
тому що далі це перетвориться в дію
вправи і тому маємо все вкладатися і теж
Ми маємо це робити серцем якщо ви це
робите серцем Я кажу робите сюпристістю
З натхненням цього це це перш за все
діти - це те що ми надихаємо найбільше
керрін ну знову ж таки
Всім дякую і особливо скажімо той
принцип Давайте будемо краще давайте
будувати де
далі тобто на має Давайте будемо
відновити майбутнє тому що ось перш за
все ми маємо думати на перспективу на
всі наші здатності і перш за все це має
бути
вкладено в основу так щоб це дійсно нас
надихало що ми будуємо майбутнє і Ми всі
маємо також скажімо дійсно крокувати
пліть обліч разом тому що це дійсно
довгий шлях ми маємо пройти всі разом і
якщо була б вірно сказано що наразі це
нагально діти не можуть чекати і тому що
це для дітей і перш за все ми тільки що
подолали кризу ковідну і наразі тепер
ризик для дітей для їхнього майбутнього
дякую
Я співкувався з деякими нашими колегами
в Чернігові в школах
котрі виявляли активну діяльність щодо
відбудови будівель
ми
також були дуже активні а там з метою
допомогти відбудувати зруйновані будівлі
якомога швидше
І ми також готовий туди повернутися і
готові надавати ту допомогу яка буде
потрібною
Мені здається що всі українці
є велетенською натхненням для усіх нас і
ми дуже натхненні а Вашої стійкістю
вашої діяльності Дуже дякую Я би хотів
завершувати потихеньку нашу
дискусію Ми дуже вдячні всім нашим
партнерам і донорам і колегам
усім вашим організаціям котрі ви
представляєте а також усім іншим
партнерам котрі нам допомагають
Ми також
нам здається що
цей час може стати дуже швидким дуже
динамічним розвитком нашої системи
освіти
і звичайно ми не просто будемо
відбудовувати І ми будемо
відбудовувати значно кращої версії того
що було А зараз я хотів би побажати вам
гарного дня
і сподіваюся що буде у нас також
наступна зустріч про на якій мої
детальніше проговоримо про відновлення
таких будову Дуже дякую також цим
учасникам щодоєднались до нас а онлайн
друзі колеги Вітаю всіх нас на останній
презентації панелі напрямку відновлення
і відбудова
презентації яка називається відновлення
побудовах то для кого і навіщо кейси
неурядових організацій і підліткових
ініціатив які змінюють життя в громадах
ми спеціально нашу третю панель зробили
такою інтерактивною зробили її
максимально живою для того аби
послухати і почути одне одного ми
покликали вас
як моїх сьогоднішніх співмодераторів
тому сьогодні окрім мене з нами буде ще
9 молодих людей підлітків це випускники
нашої програми його актів Сьогодні
хлопці з Михайла Коцюбинського навіть
щось розповсюджували інформацію та про
ті проєкти які реалізовують і
ми зібрали ті громадські організації ті
благодійні фонди які реалізовують
проєкти для підлітків або між нами
стався такий діалог або ми почули одне
одного або ви могли сказати що у вас
болить що
потрібно зробити що ми дорослі можемо
зробити для вас аби ви реалізовували ще
більше крутих проєктів а і ми в свою
чергу запитати у вас І що вам власне
потрібно та тому що ми теж формуємо цю
Жан до дня Я думаю які проєкти нам
реалізовувати наша зустріч сьогодні буде
умовно поділена на дві частини в першій
частині я попрошу своїх колег поділитися
інформацією про ті проєкти які вони вже
реалізовуються бо планують реалізовувати
для того аби життя в громадах було
насиченішим цікавішим саме про проєкти
які націлені на дітей на підлітків а
після цього я знаю що у вас є купа
запитань і у наших
представників громадських організацій
також є купа запитань до вас і тому
другу половину другу частину нашої
зустрічі ми присвятимо саме відповім на
ваші запитання
У нас сьогодні така гендерна нерівна
панель Роман я почну з вас якщо вони Але
у нас тут гарний баланс гендер там
сьогодні на нашій першій панелі
[музика]
Роман Грищук це член комітету Верховної
Ради України з питання освіти науки
інновацій Я буду по черзі представляти
кожен кожного з спікерів сьогодні тому
що поки ми дійдемо до наступного ви вже
забудете хто це так Роман на сьогодні Ян
наш модератор першої Тунелі запитав у
Сергія бабака чим власне займає це
комітет освіти наука інновації Я думаю
це дуже доречно запитання і хоча Можливо
якщо ви знаєте на нього відповідь знаєте
чи не дуже чим займеться комітет
чесно не дуже
і це
дізнатись Чим же займається комітет
точно цікаво тому Роман перше запитання
коротко Чим ви як комітет займа
Так Всім привіт Я вперше такому форматі
виступаю коли ти з мікрофоном але всі
тиші і всі тільки в навушниках
хоча ми великі великі досвід виступив
тому цікава така штука в країні взагалі
Влада розподіляється на законодавчу
виконавчу і судову Да ви це знаєте з
шкільного курсу
законодавчі Влада встановлює закони за
якими живе суспільство виконавча влада
виконує ці закони судова дивиться за тим
щоб виконали правильно так от
Міністерство освіти і науки всі знають
Це виконавча гілка влади через кабінет
міністрів законодавча гілка влади єдина
це Верховна Рада України Верховній Раді
України всі депутати поділені по
комітетам залежності від напрямку які
вони обрали своєї роботи там є комітет
аграрної політики економічної з питань
бюджету з питань національної безпеки є
комітету освіти комітет-освіти - це
депутати які якраз відповідають за
освітні законодавства тобто якщо є якісь
зміни в законі які стосуються освіти
науки
першочергово розглядає комітет освіти
потім рекомендує чи не рекомендує
Верховній Раді приймати ті закони
не Міністерство освіти саме комітет
приймає Ну і те що Сергій я не знаю чули
ви його відповіді чи ні це основна Наша
задача приймати закон друга - це
контрольна функція в народі депутати
вони обрані народом і ми можемо
контролювати Міністерство освіти
контролювати інші центральні органи
виконавчої влади в рамках наших
контрольних функцій а запитувати чому
так а не Так чому ви не виконуєте ту
норму закону чи іншу чому у нас тут є
питання до витрат державного бюджету
отакі от такі Тобто це функції комітету
Верховної Ради і в принципі народних
депутатів України приймати закони
скажи коли ви прий зробити закони чи
ставити ви себе на місце
підлітків на місце дітей на місце тих
заради кого ви це робите чи згадуєте
свої історії шкільні А от як би Хотілося
вам що ви було вам в користі чи вже
забули як це було ні звичайно тільки так
і є щоб ви розуміли ну закон це не
детально прописано всі декілька рівень
декілька рівнів законодавства но найвища
це закон України він детально розписує
Ну там
невелику кількість речей далі йдуть
нормативно-правові акти Кабінету
Міністрів які деталізують деякі норми
закону да потім ідуть вже там стандарти
освіти все інше Тобто ми в комітеті
освіти не вирішуємо що вам читати будуть
на предметі зарубіжна література Ми
навіть в законі не прописуємо що має
бути предмет Зарубіжна література Та то
це все нижче Ми якісь такі загальні речі
регулюємо звичайно Коли у нас от
останніми роками питання державної
підсумкової атестації буде вона чи не
буде це регулюється законом
в якому форматі ЗНО буде це регулюється
це регулюється законом і от декілька
років підряд починаючи з коронавірусу у
нас стають питання ми законом дозволяємо
проводити ДПА в цьому році чи ні в якому
форматі проводиться зовнішнє незалежне
оцінювання зараз дискутується які
предмети мають бути в зовнішньому
незалежному оцінюванні у національному
тесті і ми це будемо прописувати в
законі і тут ми себе ставимо на місце
школяра більше того на місце школяра
вчителя батьків В нинішніх ситуаціях не
можемо відходити від контексту того як
ви зараз навчаєтесь з якими викликами ви
з якими викликами ви зіштовхуєтесь Ну і
що нам потрібно для того щоб там
майбутні випускник школи був був там
гарним громадянином України Минулого
року ми дуже дискутували з приводу
історії України да чи треба Вона
обов'язково чи ні І от ви маєте треба чи
ні
треба Да у нас якраз і от минулого року
У нас ця дискусія зайшла
до вашого питання Ця дискусія зайшла
всередину року да тобто уже почався 11
клас для випускників і пішла пішла
дискусія по історії України чи треба
вона щоб була обов'язково чи ні і тут Ми
якраз незважаючи на позицію нашу що так
треба
комітет тоді став на
важко сказати на захист на позицію
старшокласників і ми сказали але цього
року ви всі не знали про те що воно ну
воно буде обов'язково увійшли в 1
вересня в школу там без чіткого
розуміння що цей щоб ви будете цей
предмет складати на національну
мультиплеменному тесті тому ми
це цього року не проводимо вона була на
вибір 50% її обрали але тоді ми дуже
багато негативу як комітет набрали на
себе через те що ви там не дозволяєте ви
там знищуєте історію України все інше А
ми тоді просто стали нас ну на позицію
ст- позицію старшокласників і цього року
ми як і обіцяли ввели закон що буде буде
історія України обов'язково не в
національному мультику предметному тесті
а в державній підсумковій атестації
тобто що будуть складати Її всі а не
тільки випускники а не тільки ті хто
будуть вступати далі в заклади заклади
вищої освіти тому от от така історія
коли ми дійсно дивимося на конкретно
зараз ситуацію Дякую
Іра якщо ти не проти я тобі поставлю
наступне запитання Ірина Озимок
засновниця саме тумерів авторка книжки у
міста є Я знаю що частина з вас сьогодні
слухали презентацію книги Іра Іри ти
працюєш з мерами міст знаєш багатьох
мерів наші сьогоднішні
учасники які приїхали до нас Бородянка
Катюжанка Михайло Коцюбинського Вони теж
намагаються які Мери зробити багато чого
корисного для своїх громад аби життя в
них було цікавішим насиченішим
аби був доступ до тих послуг до яких
немає зараз вочевидь через через війну
що найперше в громади А скажіть чи ви як
фонд в Nissan тому що ти також а-а
працює що фондів нісеп і якісь проєкти
для підлітків реалізовуєте і щоби ти як
засновниця самі тумерів як людина яка
працює з дорослими людьми які вже
безпосередньо обирається для того аби
життя в громадах було кращим А що буде
порадила нашим підлітками зараз в цьому
віці зробити такого щоб
людям і громадах було цікавіше жити
Дякую за питання і за можливість
долучитись до цієї конференції Мені
здається перше що я порадила це включити
предмет у міста є Я теж програму
користуючись нагодою там можна можна
розглянути але ну це і жарти і на жарт
тому що це насправді ми кажемо книжка
але це більше ніж книжка боє шкільна
програма і в Польщі для українських
дітей Ми спробували зробити Урбан клубу
тобто такі позашкільні зустрічі де якраз
діти напрацьовували ті ідеї змін які їм
хотілось впроваджувати і Мені здається
це такий важливий інструмент який мав би
бути в Україні і зараз ми хочемо такі
Урбан клубу запустити в 10 пілотних
українських містах там де відносно
безпечно нас вже є зголошені молодіжні
організації до них можна долучатися і по
суті Що Ми пробуємо робити через ці
клуби такий по суті гуртки це приміряти
оці ролі дорослих робити симуляції
певних складних ситуацій для прийняття
рішення в містах в громадах аби оце
підростаюче покоління навчилися десь на
симуляційних іграх це правда але це
дорослі історії там про революцію
бізнесу і громада проти та або про
засмічення якоїсь річки тобто все те що
з чим ми зіштовхуємося в дорослому житті
до того аби коли вони стануть вже
дорослому Будуть десь працювати Вони
з цим ближче але скажімо вже обрані
місця міста чим селища це не обираємо ми
просимо зголоситися і у нас є
10 міст молодіжні центри в 10 містах і
це і Вінниця Хмельницьке
івано-франківськ Тернопіль Львів
чи там може таке бути на Київщині
може бути але Дивіться все чому
рухаємося це добровільна історія так
Тобто ми просимо зголоситися Ми даємо
розроблену програму ми даємо там
підтримку ми даємо якусь якесь
партнерство ще навіть з або з місцевим
бізнесом Як у нас було наприклад у
Любліні де є учасники могли піти в IKEA
і дослідити наприклад що таке
енергозберігаюча лампи яка між ними
різниця і так далі І це дуже цікаво воно
все дуже практичне дуже інтерактивне це
не сидіти слухати якісь занудні лекції
так а це проживати якісь історії але
щоб я хотіла сказати з нашої попередньої
розмови я познайомився з кириловим
і я думаю я навіть не знаю чи потрібно
значно не ми маємо радити їм що робити а
навпаки вони вже дуже добре знають що
порадити меру голові громади що робити
Так і я з якимось сумом
процитую Кирила так І поясню чому суму
тому що він сказав то я знаю яка в нас
проблема нам корупцію треба подолати так
і в десятому класі молодь дуже чітко це
розуміє і вони не кажуть Вони не сказали
слухайте нам треба скейт-парк так тобто
або нам треба там новий торговий
розважальний центр вони говорять про ці
дорослі наболілі речі і це мені здається
показує наскільки молодь має бачення цих
потреб і ми вже довго Працюємо з молоді
і ми бачимо що ці їхні потреби на місто
на громаду вони дуже дорівнюють нашим
потребам потребам дорослих і
відображають їх і ще один проект який ми
зараз запустили
він
для громад саме для менших громад там
вже теж от буквально кілька днів тому ми
оголосили переможця у нас було 300 понад
300 заявок на створення центрів
спільнототворення або з іншого боку це
англійськими це центри розвитку громади
у громадах є клуб бібліотека якісь там
дім культури так і
дуже часто це ця будівля є такою яка не
дозволяє якось такого класного розвитку
і ми зробили такий конкурс що громада
може отримати мільйон гривень але
продумати як спочатку є трошки вимоги
для
самої будівлі Вона має бути основна наша
вимога що вона має бути безпечною і
доступною Так навіть якщо там буде не
найкращий ремонт Так але вона важлива
щоб вона була доступна щоб будь-хто міг
туди прийти як поспілкуватися зі своєю
громадою а далі там має бути програми
для усіх категорій які проживають в
громаді для молоді для дітей для літніх
людей виявилось що дуже багато шкіл
літнього віку так дитя дуже багато Але
ми теж хочемо щоб це були такі практичні
речі і теж зараз є 10 громад в яких
стартують ці проекти Мені здається це ну
ми хочемо показати таку цукерочку знаєте
було стало коли було якась стара
бібліотека і яка має нове дихання щоб
було враження що ми приїхали за кордон
якраз там роль молоді дуже потрібна від
такого дизайну Я б сказала який знаєте
щоб сучасний подих там був так до цього
наповнення проектів і щоб це було таким
дієвим інструментом дитячої участі у
житті громади і міста
Дякую тобі
Аню якщо ти не проти давай продовжуємо
з тобою Я думаю що Анна та спікерка яку
ви знаєте найкраще та на новосадці
засновниця благодійного фонду сейф після
деокупації Київщини Чернігівщини
я буду просто ми як команда так тобто
тому що я також є директоркою
благодійного фонду сейф
поставили собі такою метою повернення
доступу дітей до дітям доступу до освіти
і
прийшли з ідеєю такого проєкту Такого
напрямку як цифрові освітні центри DLC в
усіх наших трьох громадах з яких ви
сьогодні є цифрові освітні центри
розкажи трошечки детальніше власне про
Цей формат Чому він ефективний чи
неефективний
де та утро альпідлі можливо і також як
власне з'явилася ідея програми юектів
яку Ми продовжуємо реалізовувати на яку
там ставимо зараз такий великий акцент
якісь можливо новини в межах програми
регіонів можливо якісь нові можливості
відкриваються теж для наших підлітків
Дякую Оленка Всім привіт дуже рада всіх
вас бачити ще раз
це провів освітні центри коли ми
починали на той момент з невеличкою
командою цю ідею Це був квітень але тоді
ще не було і але що тоді були було це
багато прихисків по країні дуже багато
жінок переїхали на Західну на Західну
країну до Львова і була ідея спочатку
зробити власне такий освітній осередки в
прихистках які були повсюду там
спортзалах якихось старих будівлях але
поки ми знайшли на це гроші і все всю
бюрократію потрібно подолали Уже слава
богу засуву звільнили
Північ і можна було займатися
відновленням доступу до освіти власне
там і прихистки стали менш актуальні
тому що люди поверталися яка частина
людей поверталася додому і але також в
цей момент стало очевидно що Росія ну
дуже прицільно била по школам так і
Чернігів місто Чернігів Чернігівська
область Київщина руйнування були Шалені
а в Катюжанці там Школа була не
пошкоджена настільки суттєво але це було
місце де була ну фактично котівня в
підвалі де
базувалися російські війська Тобто там
було трошки інша Інша ситуація не менш
страшна і цифрові освітній центр це було
таке рішення швидке по тому як відновити
доступ це такі собі великі обладнані
простори які ми ремонтували
забезпечували всім необхідним
віддидактики до гаджетів якихось інших
там з тем штук але ще головне
допомагало забезпечити це роботою
тютерів от власне як Анатолій з
катюжанки роботи яких ми підтримували і
які займалися власне з дітьми Це був
такий формат О дякую Навіть є
презентація клас я забула це
це був такий швидкий варіант як
повернути дешево Ну як дешево дешевше
ніж відновити школу і більш-менш швидко
доступ хоча б до якоїсь освіти
позашкілля це ж ви бачите на екрані це
Городня це те що ми вже зробили трішки
пізніше Це Чернігівська область це
Прикордоння прикордо з Білорусі і Росією
городні дуже пощастило вони прямо з
двома одразу межують і Ці діти Вони рік
були в сиділи вдома і коли в нас
з'явилися кошти попрацювати саме Там ми
зробили такий Спейс в укритію це було до
так стало після діти туди досі ходять
тусять там з тютерами мають більш-менш
комфортний простір для для навчання це
таке собі позашкілля це не вирішує
проблему доступу до освіти це не є
повноцінне навчання але наприклад в
Богданівці ми поєднали два бюджети на
DLC і ще знайшли додаткові гроші зробили
з будинку культури повноцінно школу Яка
фактично зараз є е-е Ну єдиним освітнім
закладом який там функціонує це укриття
в андріївці яке це біля бородянки про
неї мало хто знає але вона постраждала
на жаль не менше ніж Бородянка також
можна презентацію вимикати я по ній не
буду йти дякую І власне Але як би робити
ремонт і відновлення це все потрібно це
критично без цього знаєте можна довго
робити тренінги в громадах Ну я вважаю
що на п'ятому тренінгу тебе вже пошлють
тому е-е дуже важливо людям які пережили
окупацію і
такі руйнування показувати на мацальні
результати роботи але стіни вони нічого
не варті без людей і тому для нас юектів
і можливість працювати з підлітками Чому
підлітки тому що це так вікова категорія
яка є дуже суб'єктною вже це критично
важливо з ними працювати І власне юектів
стали нашим таким рішенням ми ми думали
як з тобою Оленка зорі Ми думали як от у
нас їде окуповані громади і є ви всі і
на жаль якщо подивитися на мапу окупації
то це як правило невелике населення
пункти села маленькі містечко я сама з
маленького містечка і чудово знають ціну
перспективам і можливостями в маленькому
місті якщо тобі хтось не допоможе то в
тебе або я всі шанси залишитися там дуже
такому не дуже доброму стані Або шукати
варіантів як виїхати в Польщу на роботу
і на жаль підлітків які пережили
окупацію на миколаївщині Харківщині
багато де їх ну сотні Ну якщо не сотні
тисяч та то десятки десятки тисяч і якщо
вам додати якусь мотивацію щось робити в
своїй громадах той великий шанс що ви
просто звідти поїдете тому що будете
шукати кращих варіантів і власне є актів
- це наша спроба допомогти дуже
предметно через навчання але через
фінансові можливості і супровід
відновлювати свої громади Я дуже рада що
насправді в нас вже є дуже конкретні
результати з вами разом
Катюжанка робить якісь нереальні речі в
себе Михайло Коцюбинське Бородянка
просто об'єднала зусилля кількох команд
і зараз ми я вірю дозбираємо разом на
облаштування майданчику Бородянці і далі
ми плануємося скейлити Зараз я вам
починаю 15
громад в Миколаївській області до саме в
деокупованих невеликих містах Ми з
Оленкою там були кілька тижнів тому Ну
от реально їдеш кожне село немає ні
школи Ні садочка немає нічого але що там
є це діти і підлітки їм потрібно якась
допомога І власне іоактів і все що ми
робимо цей предмет для цього Вибачте що
довго Так ми попросимо трошечки згодом
поділитися вас поділитися вашими
історіями та того як ви взяли участь у
вієкті ще от це вам дало і де ви зараз
на якому етапі реалізації ваших проєктів
Таню Google Таня Коврига виконавчий
директорка освітньої фондації go-global
теж робить чимало для підлітків власне
ви були Одним із перших хто на поставив
питання підлітків на серед освітні
гаошек на таку на перше місце А ви
робили кемпи
вивчення англійської мови потім воно
переросло в більшу діяльність А у вас є
крутий за себе і я би хотіла бути
поділилася з нашими учасниками тим що
зараз Google робить для підлітків які є
можливості перспективи Куди вони можуть
подаватися на які проєкти на які можливо
грант Я не знаю дякую Оле Оленко Дякую
можливість по-перше Всім привіт Дякую що
ви тут
так в принципі напевно буквально з
першого дня
[музика]
масштабного вторгнення
навіть я би сказала так і ми включилися
і нас включили наші волонтери тому що go
Global - це насамперед до війни була
спільнота яка працює з волонтерами з 80
країн світу це Волонтери які приїздили в
Україну які ми робили там вот кемпи
навчання
англійська мова
совскіли і так далі І от спочатку війни
якраз Да там буквально в перший день
включилися наші волонтери і включилися
діти насправді діти Тінейджери підлітки
ну тобто такі як ви і Ми зрозуміли що
це потрібно робити і робити тому що
ви це якраз той голос
який дозволяв бути почутими тому що
розповідали
Реальні історії ділилися своїми
історіями ділилися цими історіями з зі
світом і так склалося що ось
робота з
молоддю у нас стала таким назибливим
фокусом і
всі проекти ми вже почали на
фокусуватися саме на них До речі Оленка
я не пам'ятаю Чи ти казала чи ні але
івектів ми робимо в партнерстві сейф
свої і дуже щасливий бо це один із наших
таких найщадливіших проектів і Дуже
радіємо за успіхи кожної команди але
Окрім цього
в чому пішли по-перше
буквально кожного місяця у нас
Ми відкриваємо набори на проекти які
саме сфокусовані для молоді
їхнє спрямування дуже різноманітне це
починаючи від тієї ж англійської мови
про яку я розповідала і зустрічі
відкриті зустрічі з волонтером Я думаю
можливо вже хтось долучався зараз у нас
ідуть відкриті уроки з англійської мови
з 8 Америки є окремо ми запустили проєкт
speaking Club які з волонтерами з різних
країн і слухайте Це взагалі такий
неймовірні речі тому що я якось хотіла
зайти просто з точки зору менеджменту
подивитися як це відбувається заходжу
дивлюся а там танці
я така думаю питаю команду А що взагалі
відбувається у нас Пекін клапан
англійська мова і що ми тут танцюємо
вони кажуть так ти ще піде на інший
спікен кап Подивився а там готують
шоколад Я думаю блін та що ж
відбувається А але насправді це От наші
волонтери і
ми старшокласники Да е-е в такий спосіб
е-е хтось вивчав танці хочеться було
онлайн хтось готував швейцарський
шоколад за рецептурою і наша волонтерка
це робила діти себе вдома це робили і це
насправді наскільки дозволяло не не
просто був да там сфокусуватися на
вивченні англійської мови а розвинути Да
такий у міжкультурний обмін дозволяло
відкритися і Ми зрозуміли що такий
проект не треба перемножувати Але це
маленька частина ще один великий проект
який у нас є і ми його реалізуємо уже
кілька років він ще був до війни це за
себе
кожен із вас
має права і з за кілька років ви вже
зможете цієї віддати свій голос і от
якраз в лікує за себе це про те що
показує всі можливості і ваші права і де
ви можете їх використати як ви можете
використати ми працюємо з підприємцями
Працюємо з лідерами думок ми працюємо з
публічними людьми із волонтерами
проводимо окремі зустрічі ви можете нам
писати на сторінку називається вліку за
себе там багато активностей ми робимо
саме для молоді в рамках До речі влюбий
за себе ми робили кілька місяців тому
у нас був такий онлайн кем тоді
якраз були відключення і ми всі такі
трохи в темноті жили але насправді був
кемп в якому бра 2000 підлітків участь
він був спокусований на совські Лах на
digitaly але Ми зрозуміли що в проектах
які робили діти дуже багато практичних
речей Тобто це не просто проекти які
відірвані від життя це проекти навпаки
які заземлені до конкретних громад до
конкретних міст нам пропонували медичні
розробки
Ну тому що це актуально зараз у всіх
були Нам пропонували екологічні рішення
нам пропонували інфраструктурні рішення
освітні рішення ну взагалі такий широкий
спектр що ми були прям шоковані і
тому
і так у нас власне виникло така ідея
маніфест повоєнної бачення молоді
повоєнної відбудови і участі в ній
насправді дуже крута річ вийшла ми її
задекларували і ділилися навіть з
першими особами держави для того щоб
нам дуже хочеться щоб вас чули щоб той
голос який у вас є щоб він вже зараз мав
вагу
щоб ви розуміли що ви потрібні тут і
зараз цій державі щоб ви розуміли які
можливості у вас зараз є Саме тут
ми готові в цьому допомагати задля цього
У нас багато напрямків і проектів ми от
зараз працюємо тісно з прикордонним
прикордонним громадами і розпочали
низку кемпів нещодавно от Ані згадувала
Городня і ще 7 громад із Чернігівщини
які виїздили
безпечний регіон і проходили інтенсив
навчальний а також і проектний
менеджмент і лідерство і просто
відпочивали тому що це діти які на жаль
не мали змоги
нормального доступу до освіти за ці
півтора року війни і ви знаєте і там так
само там ну такі унікальні історії і це
не про ну тобто діти тут розповідають
про те як е-е
заходили російські війська як танки
зупиняли це реальні історії і тут же ж
розповідають Попри це все дуже ж
розповідає що от вони не чекають що їм
хтось допоможе вони розуміють що там
треба наводити лад своїй громаді вони
пішли там підприємства яке вижило і
сказали дайте нам техніку А ми будемо
робочою силою ми тут розчистимо оцей
простір і зробимо його комфортним для
себе для інших людей тому що ми хочемо
відпочивати тобто Вони шукають
можливості вже і це свідчить про те що
ви маєте надзвичайно великий потенціал
ви розумієте що ви хочете його
реалізувати і реалізувати тут і зараз і
ми з вами про те щоби вас підтримати в
цьому в нас найближчим часом ми будемо
відкривати менторську річну програму
підтримки саме спрямовано на 10-11 класи
яка буде включати в себе і лідерство і
проектний менеджмент і
ще низку активностей а також і допомогу
з підготовкою до здачі мультимедійного
тесту і наздоганянням освітні втрат якщо
вони є
найближчим часом це будуть поки що
прикордонні
регіони які зараз мають проблему із
доступом Але тим не менше Ну насправді
можна багато говорити і довго про всі
ініціативи які спрямовані але я хочу
сказати що
ви це якраз наше завтра і От коли я собі
задаю питання А хто прийде після нас то
мені не те що були не соромно мені
спокійно тому що я вірю що вам
вибудовувати державу і ви з цим
впораєтесь напевно навіть краще ніж ми
тому Дякую вам дякую Таня а я вас
заохочу підписатися в Інстаграмі на
сторінки в ліпу за себе Google якщо ви
ще не підписані Там дуже багато цікавої
інформації для вас
справді ми реалізовуємо наш проєкт його
актів спільно з
освітньою фантацією Google Global а-а
почали реалізовувати перший партнери Які
в нас підтримав Це був американський
фонд співвіт FM Америка ми його
називаємо українським як повернись живим
в Америці так як в Україні повернеться
вам і також наш партнер - це
європейський центр вергелем да і
буквально ось дня Ми у вівторок ми
стартували новий велик в нову велику
програму слідкували там футболіває та за
команду ми будемо вас просити їх
мендерити бо ви ж уже цей шлях пройшли
вони чи ні і
Європейський центр вергеленда е
підтримав Власне цей новий етап програ-
програми
[музика]
з нами сьогодні є Ольга Донець Ольга є
координаторкою програми демократична
школа яку також реалізовує центр на олія
попрошу також розповісти про те що це за
програма які можливості відкривають для
підлітків і чи може бути корисна та Всім
привіт дуже рада всіх вас бачити
насправді
чому кажу що рада бачити що насправді
цей весь великий такий пафосний
серйозний захід да це все заради вас бо
ми обговорюємо освіту можливості різні
на складні програми Міністерства освіти
Да ви сьогодні я думаю побачили цілу
палітру різних організацій різних
програм нових складних слів але це все
робиться заради того щоб вам було цікаво
вчитися дуже простими да такими словами
щоб ваша школа була демократичною власне
як і ідея нашого проекту програми
великої яка вже 7 років працює в Україні
ми безпосередньо працю програма
демократична школа безпосередньо працює
для вас але через ваших вчителів Тобто
ми надаємо різні підтримки можливості
освітні програми
підтримуємо вчителів заради того щоб оці
цінності думаю що сьогодні чули багато
що нова українська школа реформа в світі
є така Да щоб оці цінності які йдуть від
нової української школи щоб кожен На і
кожен з вас а відчув це на собі Да щоб
ви хотіли зранку вставати іти до школи
щоб ви хотіли зустрічатися з друзями з
вчителями Щоб така була освітнє
середовище було безпечним цікавим Ну І
от в програмі такий акцент на це але ще
хочу сказати про те що ми працюємо під
такою парасолею громадських організацій
які працюють в сфері неформальної освіти
підніміть руку Хто знає що таке
неформальна освіта або чув хоча б що це
таке
о прекрасно супер друзі а насправді Та
ми зараз багато і в реформи нової
української школи Там говоримо що ми
трансформуємо цінності неформальної
освіти в формальну освіту най формальна
освіта це те коли ми з вами маємо якісь
навчання да вчимося поза школою поза
програмами які є офіційними програмами
затвердженими міністерствами освіти але
я виключення звичайно
але це
таке така освіта яка формує знання
цінності ставлення навички Я думаю що
якраз проект в якому ви брали участь
берете участь в Фін якраз є в
неформальній освіті І це те що ви робили
поза школою Да дуже цікаво почути про
результати участі ваших проекті І хочу
сказати що є таке знаєте ходять такі
різні стереотипи коли чують неформальну
освіту думаю що це про нудні тренінги Да
бо у всіх ми маємо різний досвід участі
в різних заходах і тренінгах насправді
вітра форм роботи з молодими людьми дуже
різноманітна і можна підбирати різні
формати роботи з молодими людьми ті які
були цікаві пані Олена вже казала що ми
хочемо почути і про ваші потреби що вам
цікаво Да задля того щоб враховувати цей
інтегрувати в проекти які ми
реалізовуємо спільно з вами я наприклад
із форматів роботи дуже сильно люблю
якщо ми говоримо про молодих людей
вашого віку це я дуже люблю дебати
підніміть руку Хто знає що це таке
дебати
а підніміть руку хто грав колись дебати
та Насправді це дуже теж класний такий
формат і ми як програма і Я особисто бо
я ще теж
залучена до роботи різних освітніх
програм в тому числі для молодих людей
ми пропагуємо ідею дебатів в школах в
шкільних клубах є багато по Україні
різноманітних шкільних клубів дебатів
дебатних це така програма яка дозволяє
молодим людям розвивати критичне
мислення навички аргументації публічного
виступу да ну це такими красивими
словами насправді це можливість
зустрітися з друзями пограти з ними
обговорити ті чи інші теми і просто
класно провести час тому це має бути
наскрізним таким коли ми говоримо да про
вас то і в школах Ми намагаємося
створити таку атмосферу щоб вчителі або
ваші ментори да от вас проектах є такі
люди які допомагають щоб створювали щоб
створювали назвали різні інструменти
роботи з молодими людьми в яких би було
цікаво в тих стінах про яких казала Аня
що якщо ми в стіни приносимо нові
формати нові ідеї нові зустрічі то ці
стіни завжди будуть кольоровими
різноманітними і там буде цікаво молодим
людям
то і Сьогодні мені здається що насправді
дуже багато можливостей для молодих
людей в плані розвитку і в тому числі в
сфері неформальної освіти я вірю в те що
ви будете використовувати участь в
проекті за підтримкою Цей вид які в вас
ментарять Які створюють такий простір де
ви вам було цікаво і я думаю що вони вам
нададуть різноманітну інформацію взагалі
про те що відбувається в Україні і про
різноманітні методи формати роботи з
молодими людьми щоб їм було цікаво і
вчитися і в школі і в позаурочний
позашкільний час я думаю що ми ще з вами
поспілкуємося в плані форматі
питань відповіді а вам дуже дякую Рада
вас всіх бачити Дякую Олю до слова у нас
є сьогодні вчителі проєкт демократична
школа на вчителів націлений є директор
школи з бородянки точно Да сьогодні А от
тому погугліть дізнайтеся і подавайтеся
і перш ніж ми перейдемо до ваших
запитань до наших гостей і від гостей до
вас тому що впевнена що запитання будуть
і в одних і в інших а-а Валентино
Валентина Валентина Полторак менеджерка
проєктів дисайд а-а Дісней займається
таким проєктом як громадський бюджет та
для підлітків е-е і теж це дуже цікавий
формат а зазвичай ми знаємо про
громадський бюджет які відкривають
органи місцевого самоврядування що таке
громадський бюджет для підлітків і
взагалі розкажіть про ці проєкти які
dside реалізовує Та ну В першу чергу
дуже рада вас всіх сьогодні бачити
Мабуть це чи не перший такий досвід коли
підлітки долучаються обговорення
освітніх реформ Це надзвичайно цінно
тому що насправді вся освіта і все що ми
робимо воно справді для того щоб ви
отримали ті шанси і ті можливості які
вам дадуть шлях у майбутнє наш проект ми
взагалі займаємося
реформою децентралізації це таке складне
слово Але по суті В 20-му році в Україні
утворились територіальні громади з
різних сіл міст вони об'єднались ми
працювали з місцевим самоврядуванням
майже по всій країні і Ми зрозуміли що
нам треба об'єднувати громадян і
об'єднувати звичайно найбільш активних
громадян на найбільш активні - це
звичайно молодь підлітки і ми
започаткували таку ініціативу яка
називається громадський бюджет на дитячі
мрії Я не знаю чи ви мене чуєте тому що
в мене трошки пропадає звук
цей ця ініціатива вона для шкіл і для
місцевого самоврядування
в тому щоби Шкільні команди навчилися
писати проєкти далі подавали їх на
спеціальні електронній платформи або
організовували вибори в школі Тобто це
коли ви формуєте виборчу комісію все
дуже подорослому самі контролюєте щоб
вибори прийшли дійсно прозоро щоб всі
хто хотів проголосувати проголосували І
власне кажучи громадський бюджет на
дитячі мрії він Почався у нас 21-му році
і до війни Ми якраз попрацювали з двома
містами шкільними командами в наших
регіонах партнерах на той момент це були
Полтава
івано-франківськ-одеса і Луганська
область розробили класні проекти з
нашими командами і почалася війна
На жаль але діти мріяли діти реально
генерували дуже круті ідеї в основному
вони стосувалися там покращення простору
в школі створення якихось таких цікавих
клубів де можна поспілкуватися Ну я
думаю що вам знайомі в принципі ці ідеї
У вас мабуть такі точно були От і таких
200 ідей ми зареєстрували на нашій
платформі і поставили це все на паузу і
коли в квітні наші громади сказали нам
що нам треба терміново продовжувати що
безпекова ситуація дозволяє це робити
громаду у нас співфінансували ці проєкти
Та вони закладали 30%, А ми давали 70 ну
це таке об'єднання партнерство для
громад це дуже важливо також долучатися
розуміти що дитячі мрії це не тільки
мрії якихось громадських організацій чи
там інших міжнародних донорів чи інших
партнерів чи може місцевого бізнесу
думаю що їх треба підтримувати і на
місцевому рівні також Ну і власне ми
продовжили цей процес там і провели
вибори провели їх під час війни в
чотирьох регіонах 12-х громадах і з 200
проєктів у нас перемогли 103 проєкти і
ми під час війни разом з громадами і Що
найголовніше зі шкільними командами ці
проекти реалізували ми я не знаю разів
10 переробляли кошториси цих проєктів Це
був дуже важкий шлях Але в цьому процесі
дуже важливо що діти долучалися що
молодь долучались що ми мріяли разом і
реалізовували втілювали ці мрії про
кращим майбутнє конкретно зараз для
конкретної громади для конкретної школи
Ну і власне після того як більшість
проектів вже була реалізована Ми
зрозуміли що нам треба розширювати наш
проект і розширили його на чернігівську
область якщо сьогодні тут є представники
Чернігівської області то ви мабуть брали
участь в шкільному громадському бюджеті
ваші школи точно брали всі школи міста
Чернігів брали в цьому участь 30 тисяч
людей проголосували за ці проекти ми
відібрали На жаль тільки два і з вересня
будемо їх реалізовувати Ну у нас
сьогодні панель називається відновлення
і відбудова і я не можу не сказати про
ще одну нашу важливу ініціативу вона
стосується
відбудови громад ми зараз наразі
відбираємо 25 громад 15 з них До речі
будуть в Чернігівській області і з ними
ми будемо створювати освітні простори
хаби де молодь може проводити час де
молодь може спілкуватися проводити
дебати взагалі думати про майбутнє своїх
громад Ми сподіваємося Що зробимо Це в
кооперації разом з молоддю тому що
місцева громада вона не може знаєте
вирішувати простір для молоді без молоді
ми в цьому переконані тому для нас дуже
важливо щоб молодь долучалась до
прийняття рішень в громадах це може
знаєте так трошки заскладно звучить але
ви наше майбутнє і якщо ви не будете
вболівати за своїх громади тобто хто ж
за них буде вболівати тому ми вас віримо
ми Вас підтримуємо Працюємо з вами і
сподіваюсь що решта громади які сьогодні
присутні також будуть подаватися на всі
наші ініціативи долучатися і активно
брати участь в громадському житті зараз
може подаватися і Київщини Чернігівщина
правильно вона є частиною нашого проекту
Проте ми там відновлюємо ірц Ну я
сьогодні задумалась над тим що мабуть
треба і громадський бюджет на дитячій
мрії також розширювати і на Київську
область
Дякую Валентина Дякую всім і у нас є ще
найменше 20-25 хвилин для того аби
хотіли більше да Кирила таку має
подивися хотілось би більше Ну Вибачте
ми дорослі багато говоримо треба
скорочуватись Так
я би хотіла аби у нас сьогодні три
команди а-а аби кожен кожна з вас кожна
з команд представилася коротко розповіла
свою історію і Давайте спробуємо по
Першому раунду запитання якщо в нас
лишиться якщо в нас лишиться що в нас зі
звуком
якщо в нас лишиться час ми підемо ще по
одному раунду запитань там давайте
почнемо з вас хлопці з Михайло
Коцюбинського розкажіть коротко свою
історію і поставте запитання можете його
адресувати або комусь одному або всім
спікерам одразу
дякую
так можна починати
Всім привіт Ми звати Євгеній Я з
Михайлом Коцюбинського ліцею Михайло
Коцюбинської громади дуже хочеться
багато всім розповісти тому що
стало для нас таким поштовхом до Великих
потужних мрії досягнення
взагалі після цього коронавірусу після
війни
з'явилась така проблема що діти
перестали особливо так комунікувати
зникла соціально згуртованість і цю
проблему потрібно було якось вирішувати
сильно ми про це не задумувались А
післяєктів ми стали це все так сказати
в реальність
ми виграли грати на 5 000 доларів від
об'єктів і зробили тренажерний зал
Після цього ми також Зараз реалізуємо
декілька проектів два дні тому в нас був
пітчинг проекту на платформі фандрейзер
Цей проект називається клас 3D
моделювання Ми також знімаємось за
гранит в розмірі 6 тисяч доларів
сподіваємося ми пройдемо суперфінали і
зможемо його виграти
Також ми зараз реалізовуємо проект це
зелена зона це ініціатива так сказати
моя і допомогли жителі Ми з зараз лівою
дерев де раніше коли наші бабусі були ще
молоді там була там площадка там весело
проводили вечори зараз там дерева кущі
були але ми їх спочатку літа все це
вичистили все повністю прибрали залучили
компанію автострада яка є учасником
Великого будівництва
вона нам допомогла
з тимою що вони розкопали русло річки
яка раніше там протікала Це була річкова
риба вона втікала в Дніпро
і в майбутньому ми зараз ще працюємо над
цим проектом Ми хочемо перетворити це
все на зону відпочинку дуже гарно з
якимись там барбекюзованами з
щоб можна було там проводити якісь
фестивалі ярмарки і яскраві вечори
круто Коли підлітки є ініціаторами таких
проєктів ставте запитання щоб ми більше
питань встигли відповідей так мене
запитання більше для
Романа
Ми всі є випускникам першої хвилі
об'єктів Ми багато працюємо над
проектами але зараз при вступі
волонтерство проєктну діяльність воно не
дуже цінеться Чи можна вас питати Як ви
до цього ставитесь Дякую дивіться в
понеділок буду реєструвати закон
[музика]
ти можеш здатись що цей бігати підставне
питання Я дуже підтримую волонтерці Я
вважаю що ми маємо інституцій
реалізувати волонтерство в
для старшокласників я хотів спочатку
сказати в школі але це неправильно для
старшокласників поясню чому не правильно
волонтерство це добровільна історія
добровільно Якщо людина хоче виділяти
свій час для якоїсь суспільної корисної
потреби Вона може це робити але вона не
зобов'язана ми маємо визнавати
результати волонтерства
в дипломах в свідоцтвах про повну
загальну середню освіту закон який буде
в понеділок реєструвати Він якраз про те
що школи можуть визнавати досвід
старшокласників волонтерство які вони
здобули за межами школи он в рамках
проекту.ua Active ви виділили велику
частину свого часу для розробки проектів
для адвокації для пошуку фінансування ви
ж це не дотримували гроші Це ваша
громадська діяльність ваша волонтерська
можна так сказати діяльність
кажуть що ви ви ви
витратили стільки-то часу для підготовки
цього проекту видають вам кожному
свідоцтво сертифікат про те що ви дійсно
волонтерили в рамках цього проекту
робили суспільно корисні потреби ви
приносите це в школу школа визнається
ваші результати і в дипломі про повну
загальну середню освіту у вас є
волонтерство
кількість годин зараховано або Ну це вже
інакше формат і ця історія зарахування
ваших знань яка потім і для пошуку
роботи і в принципі приємно що що ми
показуємо готовий законопроект готовий
підзаконка для того щоб Міністерства
швидко це прийняло Цього року я думаю це
будуть пілотні історія а з наступного з
наступного якщо підтримує Верховна Рада
законопроект то з наступного року можна
дійсно в визнавати це свідоцтво але ну
знову ж таки ми розуміємо волонтерство
для нас з одного боку це ми робимо перш
за все для себе але з іншого боку
держава має як мінімум визнавати ваш цей
здобутий досвід
є освітні системи які без волонтерства
без досвіду волонтерства навіть не
видають видають атестати шкільні Тобто
це є Обов'язковою умовою закінчення
школи Там певна кількість годин
волонтерства тому це дуже круто А
давайте продовжимо так давайте
продовжимо збору Діанки хто Кирило чи
хтось своєю командою я Катюжанка
Перепрошую так як так так е-е
розкажіть трішечки свою історію так І
через що прийшли і був досвід І що
робити зараз і питання Я взагалі мав
починати Це цей виступ з Добрий день
пані та панове але тут
Добрий день Мене звати гарного Кирил
я лідер команди речники майбутнього
катюжанської відразу розкажу про нашу
ідею ми збираємо пластик його
переробляємо на 3D нитку середня нитки
на 3D принтері друкуємо деякі деталі для
ЗСУ відправляємо їх на фронт Звісно ж і
в майбутньому плануємо друкувати не
тільки для ЗСУ тому що для того ще
Сподіваємось що найближчим часом
перестанемо друкувати не ЗСУ по своїм
причинам так а тепер трошечки про нас це
прозвучала як інтрига по своїй Ми
чекаємо просто закінчення війни
розумієте тоді звісно так тепер трошечки
про нас
наша команда утворилася на підставі
проекту юектів
навесні цього року
протягом кількасот дискусій та безлічі
зміни день ми все-таки вирішили це з
основною концепцією повезли її на пішинг
в Київ і приїхали з довгоочікуваним
нашим улюбленим білетом на реалізацію
проєкту тому що ми поступилися п'ятьма
тисячами доларів протилежній команді
чому Ніхто з нас відповіді дати не може
але руки наші не опустились
за допомогою якоїсь деякої підтримки
наших улюблених народних депутатів
нам організували
нам організували пітчинг у Львові
Ми поїхали туди розповіли про нас про
проєкти вже у нічному плацкартні їхали з
неймовірним чеком в 5 тисяч доларів
приємно виснаження ми повернулися додому
розпочали реалізацію проєкту на даний
момент вже надрукована більш ніж півтори
тисячі різноманітних деталей відправлено
з десяток партій семи бригадам на фронт
Також ми вже своїми золотими руцями
зробили кабінет
зробили в ньому ремонт і з кожним днем
все прогресуємо та прогресуємо
запитання наше запитання полягає в тому
що
гарненько
чи можна сказати що наш проєкт вже
повністю реалізований На жаль чи на
щастя ні і просто з кожним днем ми цей
прогресії нашого проєкту в моїй башці
наших нашої команди з'являється купа
безліч просто якихось таких ви знаєте
шалених ідей на які потрібно
фінансування і от питання не до
конкретної особи до всіх хто краще знає
це той відповість як залучати інвесторів
це можуть бути українські інвестори
міжнародні інвестори говоримо про
інвесторів в цілому як їх залучати на
такі проєкти
відповідь на це питання друзі А я знаю я
знаю а я знаю
[сміх]
Ну що хтось
Іра знає Іра теж знає
Мені здається навіть оця коротка
презентація показала Що пітчите Ви
вмієте так і з цим Все буде добре бо
пітчинг - це один з дуже важливих етапів
пошуку фінансування але
все ж таки почнемо з попередніх етапів
Мені здається що навіть те що ви
нащупали цю тему так і отримали
фінансування показує про те що ви
зрозуміли що
стартапи проекти Вони працюють тоді коли
ви вирішуєте якусь проблему вони
народжуються там коли вирішується якесь
проблема А коли і те що ми говорили нам
попередній нашій дискусії наприклад тема
екології вона є настільки актуальною що
той самий
колишній мер
нью-йорка Майкл блумберг який є дуже
багатий який філантроп попри те що він
вже давно не мерили він заснував
благодійну організацію і вони фінансують
дуже багато проектів зокрема екологічних
міських молодіжних і так далі тому є
кілька критеріїв перше - це проблема яку
ви у вас має бути точно
перевірка того що
ви це рішення яке Ви придумали вам треба
його протестувати що воно точно спрацює
що хто ваші конкурентне і ідея має бути
теж в якийсь момент вона не може
залежати від грошей донорських а в якісь
момент Вона має бути
Ви маєте знайти оцю фінансову модель так
і це Це дуже-дуже важлива Але мені
здається що
мати ще ту команду яка покриває от якраз
ці таланти це дуже важливо далі от
шукайте можливості шукайте де можна
запічити кому можна запічити мені
здається вони не переживаєте говорити з
дорослими і є дуже багато фондів наш в
тому числі Який такий проект міг би
підтримати запам'ятайте Western
escenterprise
добре можна поговорити Таня хотіла щось
додати так
я хотіла сказати на прикладі сьогодні Да
Кирил вдало використовуєте нас дорослих
в парламенті багато грошей я знаю
поза парламентом
дивіться спробуйте реально соціально
підприємництво тобто по суті у вас вже у
вас вже є звіт що ви можете робити у вас
є 3d-принтері Я з чого ви можете робити
з позиціонуйте себе як бізнес без мети
отримання прибутку для вас як для
бенефіціарів а для вкладення потім ваші
ж якісь ідеї і поводьте себе як бізнес
Кому ви можете надати послугу Кому ви
можете надрукувати Почніть з тих хто є
уже в Катюжанці ну тобто ваші якісь
локальні локальні бізнеси хто чимось
займається скажіть дивіться давайте
комерційні на комерційних умовах з вами
попрацюємо ми вам щось надрукуємо Що вам
треба вашій вашій діяльності ці гроші
які ви нам дасте ми для підтримки себе і
для розвитку тобто спробуйте себе з
позиціонувати як підприємство як в мене
як Як малий бізнес
але оскільки ви там там на базі школи
працюєте то це там соціальне
підприємництво в цьому немає нічого
поганого може навіть і добре
так реально новосадках Лише ти їм робиш
Та я тут просто Спочатку так і
розгубилася бо хотіла сказати що дуже
багато зараз можливостей але потім мені
прийшла така думка
насправді Ваш проект про який ви кажете
це не тільки про екологію це про участь
молоді да Тобто це це про підхід участі
і Цей підхід дуже підтримується радо
Європи в Європі є такі європейські
молодіжний фонд І от пілотний проект ваш
Він дуже сильно я прям бачу вже що можна
подати і зараз для України є спеціальний
конкурс Так звичайно там Це трошки вище
вже да там більше грошей більше
відповідальності має бути громадська
організація Але я думаю що у вас така
велика підтримка і дуже класна ідея і у
вас вже є досвід Да ви кажете що проект
закінчився чи ні Ну ви ще його там
проаналізуєте оцінити та зробите
висновки і потім як можете на основі
свого пілота подавати нову ідею і робити
її навіть якщо у вас є друзі
з якими ви паралельно працюєте є навіть
різні ідеї але якщо наскрізно буде те що
ви говорите про участь молодих людей ви
співпрацюєте з громадськими
організаціями Які у вас є в громаді і
співпрацюєте з місцевою Владою Да ви
ведете перемовини відстояти свою точку
зору можете розказати задля чого Чому це
важливо для вас я вже бачу Ваш проект до
жовтня місяця відкритий спеціальний
конкурс для України саме для українських
громадських організацій то успіхів вам
ця фонд запам'ятали як називається
європейський молодіжний фонд супер І ще
запитання від команди з бородянки
коротко про себе і запитання і побіжимо
дивитись нагородження вчителів
Доброго дня
Хочу ще розказати що не можу сказати
свого враження Приємно що
на початку весни Коли нам розповіли про
цей проект то у нас десь у 10 учнів
нашого нашого ліцею була така лише гола
ідея але зараз ми в такому місці
розмовляємо з таким поважними людьми то
хочу сказати що ще вам дякую за втілення
таких ідей і одразу до теми Мене звуть
Нікіта Я є представником команди з
бердянкі і у нас трапився доволі таки
унікальної випадок коли
між командами з одного населеного пункту
обирали Кому ж видати грошовий фонд а
другим білет на реалізацію ідеї між
нашими двома командами розділили що
iPhone в 5 тисяч доларів тому для
раціонального вирішення нашої проблеми
та створення нашого проекту Ми вирішили
об'єднатися
але все одно нагальною проблемою є
нестача фінансів
ми активно залучаємо іноземних спонсорів
благодійні організації і вони
якісно нам допомагають втілені наші якої
є мульти спортивний комплекс
Проте мені здається основним нашим
спонсорам должны бути люди які бачать
нашу проблему які розуміють і які є в
найбільшій можливості на допомогти а
саме це місцева влада в Бородянці стався
такий унікальний випадок що у нас був ой
вибори голови місцевої ради І ми грубо
кажучи створюємо наш проект під
керівництвом спочатку однієї людини яка
грубо кажучи так
відносно стало з нашою проекти і не
звертали на наші потреби а другий вже
нинішній голова він активно залучається
до нас і
мені так я нагальне питання от якими
інструментами можна залучати владу до
реалізації молодіжних проектів і з цього
випливають Угі ще питання Якщо можете
відповісти
що робити коли Влада не зацікавлена
якими інструментами потрібно діяти І що
що потрібно організовувати У нас є два
представ на один точно влади Аня
представниця колишньої влади Тому
нинішньої давай
колишня представниця
перше влада - це не завжди результат
інколи ви більш спроможні ніж
представники Влади не треба розглядати
от те що голова погоди в обо голова нам
пообіцяв допомогти як те що проект
вдасться проект здатися може і без того
що влада буде підтримувати чи якимось
чином бути долучено більше того взагалі
краще розраховувати на те що можна без
без якоїсь без якогось такого роду
підтримки це перше щоб ви зрозуміли Я
просто не до кінця почув про про проект
це
спортивний майданчик Бородянці ви почали
говорити тезу і правильно тезу про те що
найкраще підтримку шукати серед тих хто
зацікавлений але ви просто потім не
зробили неправильно виключно це місцева
тільки місцева Влада місцеві жителі хто
найближчий хто буде користуватися цим
майданчиком крім вас ви ж його не тільки
для себе робите ось тут от поле поле яке
потенційно може бути бути для підтримки
Я дуже люблю Бородянку був там
неодноразово після повномасштабного
вторгнення після звільнення бородянки
розуміє наскільки там зараз не вистачає
оцих от місць де ви могли зустрічатися
де ви могли б ви могли займатися місцеві
підприємства оце з ким працювати
дивіться які не хочуть йти на головну
сцену хочу з вами спілкуватися Таня
давай 30 секунд іще Валентина медунку
бізнес проаналізуйте який бізнес працює
наприклад а автостради тут називали
велика компанія яка До речі дуже
допомагає ЗСУ якщо ви їм з конектитеся і
запропонуєте рішення в якому вони себе
побачили Ну типу у них фокус ЗСУ
Запропонуйте їм там об'єднатися зробити
на там на принті запчастини вони до речі
із антитілами з фондом з Тарасом тополюю
працюють
Я працювала з ними от ну реальний
Варіант А стосовно влади моя вам порада
Давайте будемо відвертимо наш час
технології соціальних медіа
комунікацій всі хочуть Трішки більше
впізнаваності Трішки більше піару тобто
пропонуйте що ви будете промотувати свій
проект тому що це соціальний проект І
тоді все буде більше можливостей
щоб вони більше включались Дякую Таня і
я бачу що нам точно потрібно нам мало
Сьогодні часу його Недостатньо тому ми
обов'язково організуємо для вас
документиську сесію онлайн та Як вам
така ідея і ми зможемо говорити що ті
питання які не змогли сьогодні А останнє
слово для Валентини
Я вже власне казала що ми працюємо з
бородянською громадою На жаль поки що не
зі школами з інклюзивно-ресурсним
центром ми його відбудовуємо я знаю
точно що обласна Влада обрала власне
Бородянку як такий пілотний проєкт
повідбудові в регіоні Тобто 100% ви
можете звернутися і до обласної влади до
того щоб вашу пропозицію врахували
привідбудові знаю що зараз вони
розробили такі класний проєкт
відновлення всього міста це такий перший
момент і другий момент ви можете
звертатись до бізнесу до соціально
відповідального бізнесу та і дуже багато
компаній працює в Київській області
зокрема знаю фонд миронівського
хлібопродукту а старта-київ також
долучається ми власне звернулись до
стартиків і вони нам зараз допомагають
відновлювати вас ще інклюзивно-ресурсний
центр тобто таких можливостей дуже
багато якщо ідея вже сформована проект
написаний то набагато легше розказати
для чого це і отримати на це кошти
успіхом
панян Ви хотіли щось сказати
так багато грошей треба там буквально
там до речі там залишилось нам тільки
мільйон
мільйон це 25 тисяч доларів
словами Бачите як тут ідеї народжуються
ви головне ні про що не забувайте
запитуйте все що вам тут зараз сказали
Куди звертатися в кого пітчите і так
далі друзі Дякую вам за дуже таку
натхненну зустріч для мене особисто
ви ви величезне натхнення і ви це наше
100% нашого майбутнього тому що саме вам
через 4-5 років Та вже насправді
відновлювати країну жити в ній а ми
дорослі тут для того аби вас
підтримувати і допомагати вам у цьому я
не дарма сказала про нашу онлайн-зустріч
ми обов'язково її організуємо зберемо
докупи всі ваші запитання аби будуть для
вас максимально корисними Дякую колеги
Дякую що приїхали до нас і пропоную іти
на головну сцену і завершувати
сьогоднішній день